- Have you ever cry wanked?
(all laughing)
- I don't dare try, to mix the...
- We know how easy it is for you.
- He hasn't read metamorphosis.
(all laughing)
- Read metamorphosis
you'll know the definition
of a cry wank.
(all laughing)
(upbeat music)
- Welcome back to this
episode of "Trash Taste"
that you just joined,
so now welcome back,
with my boys, (Joey
laughing) Joey and Garnt.
- Welcome to this
episode of "Trash Taste".
- Welcome back, I'm sure you...
- Welcome back to "Trash Taste".
- As you should with every
"Trash Taste" episode,
you should go and watch the
previous episodes in order,
without breaking them
then come to this one.
- We have a watch order, it goes one,
then two, (Joey laughing)
then three.
- Whoo controversial.
(laughing)
- Wow.
- Are you gate keeping
(Gigguk laughing) this?
- What if I wanna watch episode four
and then go back to episode one?
- Bro you're not a real
fan (Joey laughing)
You got to start from part one,
and then part two all the way to part 20.
- And I watch halfway through part three.
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry Joey.
- You're a real fan, if
you see me over here,
a special episodes, then we
know if you're a real fan.
- If you don't know what
we're talking about,
don't worry about it.
- Sorry Joey.
- [Host] This is bullshit.
- What are we talking about today?
- I don't know, what we're
gonna talk about today Joey?
- We hardly ever know what
we're gonna talk about
- I feel like we have a
few ideas we want to do
but we'll save the special ones coming up.
But, I mean yesterday,
I'm gonna tell you a little story boys.
- Okay, yeah, for it's
Connor's Story Time,
it's getting graphic
- Connor's Story Time.
- I went to the DMV.
- Gathered around the camp, oh my God.
(Joey laughs) This is
already sounding horrible.
- This is not a campfire stories.
- This is already sound horrible
- So as you guys know,
none of us have the
ability to drive in Japan,
but we all have the licenses
in our own respective country.
- Yes.
- And I thought well, one of
us needs to do it, I'll do it.
I like driving, Garnt hates driving
and Joey is just Joey.
So Joey just stands there being like,
I don't want to do that.
Joey doesn't want to spend
a whole day at a DMV.
- No.
- (laughs) And more probably
- Yeah.
- My relationship with driving is that
it's literally serves a purpose.
Like I don't care if I can
get from point A to point B
in a way that's like other than driving
or someone else can drive me.
I don't care if I have to
drive, I'll fucking do it but--
- I can afford an Uber now.
- I'm convinced that you
wanted to become a rich person
just to get a chauffer (Joey laughs)
that's like, eventually.
- That's the dream right?
- That's the dream.
Okay, like okay I don't hate driving,
what I hate is parking.
My gods, like I can.
- Just like at all?
- The thought of parking,
yes 'cause I suck at parking, Okay?
I barely passed my test
when it came to like parallel parking.
(Joey laughs) The thoughts
of parallel parking
gives me nightmares.
Like I wake up in a
cold sweat and I'm like,
what if the car doesn't fit?
I'd make a fool of myself,
like spending 10 minutes
trying to get into the slot,
but (Connor laughing)
- Because everyone's been
on the other end, right?
Where you're trying to
watch someone parallel park
and it's like, come
on, it's not that hard.
And then when you actually
go to do it's like,
oh, it's that hard (all laughing)
- I somehow nail like the hard parking
and then take 15 attempts for
the shittiest easiest parking,
when there's like a 100 people around me
just watching me like really embarrassing.
But yeah, I wanted to get my license
'cause you know, I wanted
to have the options open.
So I feel like you can still explore
a lot of Japan without a car.
- [Host] Yeah.
- It's just some places,
you know the further I...
- Once you're outside of Tokyo,
you pretty much need a car.
- Becomes a little more difficult
especially if you wanna
really explore a lot.
Like if you want to stick
to the main tourist stuff,
there's this buses and
stuff and you'll be fine,
but I wanted to drive and
I mean, nothing goes better
with my Beep Boop Daft
Punk music than driving.
(Joey and Garnt laughing) I
love driving with music man,
it's so like smacking
that wheel, you know.
(all laughing)
- Smacking that wheel is
like, you're like a fucking,
you are like a dad.
- I don't know.
And I love it, I love all of it.
So I thought, you know what?
I'm going to get my license,
'cause if you have a
British license in Japan
and a select few of the
countries, a lot of European ones,
they said like America,
but only Hawaii and Alaska.
It was like, so only Hawaii
and Alaska can do it.
If you're from any of the countries
where you don't, from those countries,
you have to do a test.
- Why Hawaii and Alaska?
- I have no idea, I don't
think it was Hawaii or Alaska,
it was Alaska and some other
country, some other state.
Which is really confusing,
'cause I'm pretty sure
don't they all drive
on the same side of the road?
- Yeah I thought so, right?
'Cause the reason why American.
- Maybe there something we don't know.
- Yeah, 'cause the reason why Americans
have to do a driving test is because
we drive on the other
side of the road, right?
But Alaska drive on the same
side of the road as Japan?
Alaskans let us know.
- Yeah, so I had to go to the DMV
and I knew it was going
to be a stressful process,
'cause it always is with any driving.
- I mean, that's just universal
but I can only imagine how
stressful it is in Japan
(Joey laughing) because the
extra layers you have to do.
- Right, because you're like,
it was already hell in my own country,
it's probably gonna be hell
again in Japan, times two.
And I have to take a translator with me.
Which is so awful.
- I'm so glad
the translator was not me (Garnt laughing)
- I was gonna ask Joey, but
then another friend offered
and I'm like.
- But then I was like
oh, you ended up at DMV?
Sorry I'm busy, I'm busy that
day, I got caught, my bad man.
- So first I gonna ask, how
long were you there for?
- I got there at 8:20 in the morning.
- Why so early?
Is it your line off?
- So
Yes, so right now,
because I'm not sure if
it's because of COVID,
but right now only 10 people are allowed
to get a foreign license a day,
in the whole prefecture.
- Wow, what?
- So it's like first come first serve.
- Yeah, so whoever serve first, gets it.
If you don't, you have to
come back at 2:30 and wait
but they give out the 2:30 slots
at the 9:00 a.m
- [Host] In the morning.
so I was in the 2:30 slot.
- Oh shit!
- Jesus!
- So I got, I queued up at 8:20.
I was told, on the website it says 9:30,
get there at 9:30.
And then I called them up and I asked,
hey what time should I get that?
They said, get that for like eight,
so I got there at 8:20 because I thought,
oh it's no one's gonna be there.
There was already like 14 people
lined up when I got there,
so I was in the second bunch.
So they only give out 10 licenses a day,
in the whole prefecture, which
is like millions of people,
for foreigners and it's like, what?
How is this a thing?
Why only 10?
Like they issue the
first 10 like I go home.
- At least it wasn't like
the bullshit like you know,
you know when they did like
a Gotcha Game and stuff.
- Right, right.
- Here's a ticket and
if you win the ticket,
you have a chance to get it.
- Wow, wow, you'll see well,
I'll tell you more about the story.
- Okay, go on.
- So it's like an hour away from me.
So I have to get up at like 6:00 AM
which is way over my like comfort zone.
I can wake up at eight and be fine.
- Like anything before 7:30.
- I feel like shit the whole day.
- Exactly.
- So I get that and we line up
and then I have to wait
an hour to get my ticket.
So I have to wait an hour to wait more.
So then I went to Coco's Diner,
which is like Coco's Richmond,
I think.
- [Host] Yeah.
- Went there, stayed there
for three and a half hours.
- [Host] Jesus Christ.
- Came back to the place,
waited another hour.
Finally got to go in.
As I'm going in, this
couple is like screaming
at the employees.
- [Hosts] Right.
- Like what the fuck or
something in Japanese.
I remembered some of it from anime.
(Joey laughing) They were
saying in the bad anime words.
I was like, that's a nappy I was like,
what happened it's like,
apparently didn't have
the right documents.
But before we went in,
they gathered us all around and were like,
"Hey some of you are gonna be
rejected today for no reason."
(Garnt laughs)
They literally said that.
They said.
- What?
- They said, "We might reject
you and not explain why."
And I'm like, what?
- What is the issued demonetization?
(both laughing)
- What do you mean,
I've come here all day.
And you've to bring like
so many fucking documents.
So you have to get like
your license translated
at a different building,
wait a few days for that.
Go to the ward office,
which is another building,
get proof that you live
where you say you live.
- [Hosts] Yeah.
- Bring your other license, your passport,
literally every single documentation
that you were ever a person to begin with.
And yeah and then they
grilled me for like an hour,
like asking me if I--
- Asking what?
- Well they so a part to
get the foreign license
you have to prove that
you are in the country
where you got your license
for six months after the fact.
So I brought tons of paperwork,
proving that I was in the
U.K at the time when I got it
in for six months.
And they just kept grilling me
and asking me pointless
questions, what I thought.
But they asked like,
"Did you have like a provisional license?
Which in the U.K and I
think in America as well.
Australia too.
- Yeah.
- You got a license
before the actual license.
They're like, did you have one?
And I'm like, obviously I
had one, I had to drive.
- Who doesn't?
- What a dumb question.
- Part of the official process,
you need a provisional before
you get a full license.
- I don't think a lot of
countries would let you
get the full thing without
doing it and I said.
- I'll speak about Thailand.
(both laughing)
- So I'm like, yeah of course I had that.
And then they're like,
"How long did it take
you to get your license"
What do you mean how long?
Did it take like a week
or did you do lessons over a long time?
I was like, I did
lessons over a long time.
Then they're like,
"Oh, how long did you have
that provisional form?"
I'm like, why are you ask?
Who cares?
Who cares how long?
- You got the full license?
- Yeah I'm like, I had it for five years.
And she was like (snorts)
(Joey laughing)
And then she asked, "why did
you have it for so long?"
And I'm like, why does
it matter how long like?
Because in the U.K, we don't have ID.
We don't carry around ID.
So most people will get
the provisional license
even if they don't intend to drive.
So I'm here explaining like
a cultural difference to her.
- I'm like, so what did you say?
- I explained that I'm like in the U.K,
we don't really have ID,
so people will get the ID.
- But that's what Japanese
people do as well.
- Is it real?
- Yeah, there's a lot
of like what we call.
- Why I'm I being grilled for this thing?
- In Japan, a lot of people are
like known as paper drivers,
which means they have the license,
but they don't have it to drive.
They just have it as a form of ID.
- Yeah, in the U.K people
get provisional licenses
because we.
- That's where I got.
- We use licenses to prove that
we can get into bars and pubs.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's pretty much the only reason
for provisional licenses.
- And even Australia.
- Yeah, so I had to wait an hour
and I was like, cool,
I'm it's all going well,
she seems to be, you know happy with it.
She's like, "Yeah okay, yeah, no problem.
"Just come back in two days."
I'm like what?
What do you mean come back in two days?
- So you didn't even get it?
- I didn't get it to
today, I didn't get it.
- Oh my God!
So you haven't got it yet?
- No
- After waiting,
how long did you wait?
- I left at 4:00 p.m and
I got there at 8:00 a.m
so that is eight hours away.
- So eight hours?
- Yeah, like eight hours.
- You wasted a whole day.
- I lost a whole day.
- To not getting a license.
- To get the paperwork,
to get the license.
- Because I remember you
telling me just before
that you were getting this.
- It's a whole of bunch of fetch quests,
this is why they love.
In fact, this is why all the RPGs in Japan
have a bazillion fetch quests.
'Cause living here is
a fucking fetch quest.
Every time you wanna do anything,
it's like, okay get
the prerequisite items.
Which you they're all
in different locations
because of course they are,
like they're not all in
the government building
because that would be so easy,
that will make life too simple.
- That's why Gotcha Game work here.
Because you even have the waiting time,
like the loading time
where you're like think
you got all the items and then
you have to like put it in
to like, fucking yeah,
you gotta a craft the item
and you've gotta wait until the item
is finished being crafted.
- And then you pull the
DOD Gotcha (Garnt laughing)
'cause you have to wait to 2:30.
- So they said I have to
come back on Wednesday,
which is tomorrow.
So I'm going there tomorrow
to do the eye test.
That's it, I do the eye test
and once I prove I'm not
fucking blind, I get my license
- Imagine if they just
rejects you after that.
- I would fucking lose temper
- So you basically spend eight hours
for someone to tell you
come back in two days?
- Yeah, basically, I know the
DMV is bad in all countries,
but in U.K I would never have it that.
- It wasn't that bad especially
with how many documents
you needed to grab before just
to get your license slide,
just be given a license as well.
- Because it's crazy because like Nabi,
who went with you is a friend of ours,
like when he went, he
had such an easy time
but I guess it's because
he got up before COVID.
- I think they've made it
a lot slower, from COVID,
like apparently and they also told me that
for some reason, because of COVID,
the amount of people
applying has gone up a lot.
- Well yeah, because no one can travel
outside of the country.
So therefore they wanna
travel inside the country.
- Yeah true, but I guess
I would have thought the other way around,
but yeah it's just.
- Speaking to you has made me less,
entirely put me off from
wanting to get a job.
- I'm glad at least someone in Trash Taste
now has a license 'cause
we're just gonna ask you
to show for us anyway.
- I want it, I even when
I don't need something,
I want to just do it because
if I have the free time,
I know there's gonna be up,
I never wanna be in the point in my life
where like, I need something
and it's gonna take.
- Oh, I mean, don't get me
wrong, I'm like that as well.
But I'm not going to go
to a DMV for eight hours
to be like, come back for
an eye test two days later.
- I didn't know they were gonna do that.
- That doesn't sound worthy to me.
So I'm glad you went through the pain
because like I said, like, I don't.
- Now we know not to do it
- Yeah, now I know not to do it
and I like driving for me is
a stressful experience anyway
but that's probably because
I've spent most of my time
driving in Thailand.
- Oh, man.
- Because I never actually
drove so much in the U.K
'cause like I grew up in Brighton
and then went to London for my job search.
So I've never needed to be in a place
where I drive frequently
until I moved to Bangkok.
And my God, driving in just
Southeast Asia, in general,
is just nothing like driving in Japan
or driving in the U.K or anything.
So let me describe what it is
like driving in one of these
kinds of countries.
- Okay.
- Okay, so in Thailand,
we don't have road rules,
we have road suggestions.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
That's kind of so we
technically have rules,
but whether people follow them or not,
is up to the individual driver.
- It's like a Mario Kart
with like a lot more death.
- It is basically, so like
you know how you change lanes,
there's like a system for
example, changing lanes.
You signal and then the
person like whether it.
- Backs off.
- Yeah, the person backs off whatever,
like whoever has the right of way.
The rights of way in Thailand goes,
okay we're gonna play this
game of chicken, okay?
- [Connor] (laughs) Oh, no.
So imagine I wanna change lanes
or someone else wants to change lane
and there's a car just like behind them
or like in the same lane.
So the person's gonna start changing lanes
and either one person backs off
or the person changing lane
backs off or we're gonna crash.
And so there's no rule to
say who has to back off.
- Right, right.
- So one of them is gonna back
off or you're gonna crash.
So it's basically who has the bigger balls
to like not give way or give away
- Who's going to be the bigger man.
- Yeah, yeah exactly,
exactly (Joey laughing)
- It is wild, I think
like Thailand looks scary.
There's other countries
that even worse I think.
There's like, I think in Saudi Arabia
the number one cause of
death is car accidents.
- I wouldn't be surprised, I mean.
- It's crazy because I don't think
any other country it's even not there.
- I mean, I went to the
Philippines a couple years ago
to go see Yankees family and
we had to drive through Manila.
And that was one of the
most terrifying things ever
because not only is there no
lanes and it's the same thing,
like it's just whoever
gets in there first,
but there's also people just on the road
just in the middle of
the road trying to cross.
- The worst thing is like
the people in the middle
of the road who have just no fear of death
and then motorcycles as well.
Motorcycles are like the
fucking, like annoying housefly
that you just can't
like fucking swat away,
but they're always and you
always need to be aware of them.
Like driving in Bangkok,
you just have to like,
you just have to mask the ultra instinct.
They just every driver, just
needs to master ultra instinct.
- You just have to like the rain men.
- (Joey laughing) The
fucking men turned on.
That's why they can all drive.
- Like the fucking observation hockey,
like permanently turned
on when you're driving.
- And it's not just the motorcycle either,
it's like one it's like a motorcycle
that's normally for like max two people
but somehow have like eight people on it.
I'm just like what?
- Like sometimes there's
just the motorcycle
and there's just like the
entire family (Joey laughing)
on the motorcycle plus the chauffeur.
- Dude that would be wild.
- It's like a clown car but a motorcycle.
- That would stressed
me out so fucking much.
- Like it's funny 'cause
Bangkok, living in Bangkok,
you often take motorcycle taxis
even though in any other
country, you would not take it.
And I described Bangkok
is like the only place
I've been to in the world,
where I will willingly
risk my life everyday
going into a motorcycle taxi,
so I can save myself from
sitting in an hour of traffic.
- Oh, my God.
- That's the kind of city
it is during rush hour.
And that's just given me a huge,
I wouldn't say fear of driving,
but just every time like
I think about driving
just gives me a cold sweat.
Like, oh, I got to get
back on that road man.
- Or you've just like perfected
your like dodging techniques.
(Garnt laughs)
- Here in the U.K by some asshole.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, yeah I go.
- So we were on, I was driving two,
we have like a yearly house party
where a lot of my friends
in the U.K catch up
and I was sitting in the
car with Alan, my Editor
Alex, Alan's girlfriend,
Sydney and D Revel House.
And so we were on like a country roads
and we had just like there
was a car in front of us,
so we just stopped.
And I like did like a
kind of like a sudden stop
'cause the car in front of us,
like did a very quick stop.
And then D was about
say nice driving Garnt.
And as he was, as like the
sound was leaving his mouth
(Joey laughing)
(mimicking a car crash)
a fucking car just like
tears in my car and it fucking
destroys my car.
- Jesus.
- And (laughs) I like my
car is fucking totaled
and the car in front of us
has the audacity to be like,
"Yeah, this was your fault by the way,
"when are you paying up?"
And the car behind us was like,
so during the interview
when the police came,
we called the police, we've got you know,
everyone got like checked up an ambulance
and apparently he just,
he was going like 60
or 70 down a country road
and he just had his eyes off the road.
He was like, "Yeah, I
just took my eyes off
"the road for a second
"and who knew a car could
creep up on me in one second?"
- Oh dear, it's terrifying
in the country roads.
It's like I learned to drive in London
but I also drive a lot in Wales.
But like, those roads in Wales are scary
'cause they're all like thick
trees and really tight roads,
especially like Wales and then
probably in Devin as well.
We were in there like
that's like fucking trucks
coming all the time on these roads.
- It's like a one way road or?
- It's two but when
you get the big trucks,
it's like you kind of just stop.
- It might as well be a one-way road,
yeah.
- So that you avoid
the road ditch, so
sometimes you'll go in like
and then normally 60 'cause
like their national speed limit.
- 60 miles right?
- Miles per hour
And then they'll just
be like trucks coming
and you really have to like.
- I feel like truck drivers
in every country are like.
- They don't give a fuck
'cause why would they?
They win every time (all laughing)
If I had a rock to destroy paper
of course I'm gonna pick rock
to fucking kill everyone.
- They're like the jokes in
the school hallway, right?
So you have to move out of the way
'cause they don't gonna move (laughs)
- Yeah, I mean that was the only car crash
I've been in but there's
been many, many close calls
as you can probably imagine in Bangkok.
Like the health and safety in Bangkok,
especially on the road, is very worrying.
- How does an ambulance get to you?
(Joey laughing) If you?
- I've wondered that exact
same question, during shower.
- Motorcycle as an ambulance,
like get in the back
- I guess you just gotta
a fucking bleed out
on the road, right?
'Cause what's even scarier all right?
is the taxi drivers in Bangkok.
It causes such a roulette wheel.
Okay, so for one, you'd
expect one of some,
one of the most dangerous
cities to drive in
to have a lot of like safety measures
on the public transports right?
So most taxis you go in the back
and there's no seat belts.
(laughing)
Some of the closest near
death experiences I've had
have been on a fucking taxi.
Because taxi drivers they don't
get paid the most as well,
so they work ridiculously long hours.
So I remember this one time I was,
I had a night out and
we stayed out till about
like 3:00 a.m, 4:00 a.m
drinking at some IZakiya
in like Bangkok whatever
and we had to go home.
And so we get a taxi home.
And the good thing about driving back home
in like the middle of like 4:00 a.m,
is it's normally driving
there it takes two hours,
but when there's no traffic,
it takes 30 minutes.
That's kind of like the time we had on
when you don't factor in traffic.
- Right.
- But we get in, it's me and Sydney
and we get in this taxi
and this guy just seems really quiet.
And then we get to the highway
and he's doing like fucking
80 to a 100 miles an hour
on the freeway, right?
And then Sydney is like
asleep in the taxi,
so it's just me and it's complete silence
and then he's just starts
like swerving a bit.
You know that thing where.
- When you wake up.
- You're like whoa, whoa.
And I'm like okay, we could
have crashed right there.
So I asked him, are you okay?
And he's like, "Yeah,
it's I'm completely good.
"I've just been up for like 36 hours."
(Joey laughs) I'm like
- Pull over pull over.
- Whoa, whoa, hold on a second
and to explain something about,
to explain like something
about Thai culture.
We have this thing called
a Mapping Lie Attitude
which the closest translation is like
(speaking in foreign language)
It's okay kind of attitude,
which you know it's great
when you're on holiday you know,
because the reason Thailand's so great
when you're on holiday is
cause everyone's so relaxed,
you know, it's stress free.
But there are some situations
where it's very not in my situation
and this was one of those situations.
So I'm asking him, are you okay?
Are you sure you don't wanna pull over?
We can get another taxi.
And he's like "map and lie,
map and lie, map and lie"
And I'm like bruh, this is a
very not map and lie situation
(Joey laughing) right now that we're in.
- I could go next to him the whole time
like slapping his cheeks.
- No, I was actually in the back seat.
No seat belt by the way.
This taxi did not have a seat belt
and this guy just I told him to slow down
and he goes, "Okay, I'll slow down."
So he goes from a 100 miles
an hour to 80 miles an hour.
I'm like bro, like brilliant, brilliant.
But.
- Everything is not map and lie.
(laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, he's like
map and lie, map and lie
I'm like every five
minutes he would just like,
I could see him nodding
off, nodding off to be like,
(mimicking a sleepy head)
- This is where you get in the front seat
and stare at him like this,
like the owl just like fucking.
- Because like Bangkok has like a highway.
So it's like a elevated highway.
So I couldn't just tell him to stop
and like and we get another taxi,
'cause we're in the middle of the highway.
- If you're a fucking Japanese taxi,
he'll stop on the highway.
They don't give fuck that crazy here.
- Yeah, so basically it
was the most stressful
half hour of rides I've ever been on.
Sydney was like
stress-free, she was asleep.
She could have died in her sleep.
- Sydney was the only one
who was map and lying.
- It's a good way to go
(all laughing) I mean.
- Yeah, I know what's up
like fucking pissed out
my mind at 4:00 a.m being like
trying to have this conversation
with this taxi driver.
I was like I was just
trying to keep him awake
and he was telling me like,
"Oh yeah, you know I've got like
"two kids waiting for me at home."
And I'm just like, dude
after this taxi drive,
go home to your fucking kids.
Just think about your kid's.
- Sleep, for fuck's sake.
- Please just think about
your kids right now.
- My God.
- And yeah, that was one
of the near life you know.
- Jesus Christ.
- That experiences I had.
- Yeah, can I come to
Thailand will be great.
I'm like, bro, what do you mean?
You make us sound like it's
fucking Jason Statham Movie
every time you talk about it, holy shit.
- Fast and furious.
- Keeping this man
awake to save your life.
What is this? (Joey laughing)
Yeah, it's like, yeah,
I'll said earlier like Japanese taxis,
they just stop anywhere,
if you noticed that.
- They have the jocks in the skill,
they don't move.
- Well, I tell them to
stop around somewhere,
they like take that literally
and they'll stop in the middle
of the fucking busy highway.
And they'll be like, here you are.
I'm like what are you doing?
Get to a side road or something.
- If you don't specify like,
can you stop like down the road?
If you just say stop, they'll
be like, okay stopping.
- They stop, if I say like
(laughs) tomorrow, they'll stop.
- I'm like, we're in the
middle of an intersection
maybe you should like, move forward a bit.
- He did that when we went
to the Roman last week
and then he stopped at the intersection,
just stopped.
- And I'm like, I'm not
getting out of the car,
we're in a fucking intersection.
- (all laughing) Like bro (laughing)
It's so weird.
I don't know 'cause they follow
road rules so strictly here.
But then for some reason
taxi drivers just don't.
And it's funny cause I noticed
on the British government
website, when you go to Japan,
it says be careful of taxi drivers
because they just stop anyway,
especially when driving.
Because if you're behind
a taxi driver in Japan,
and you're driving be careful.
He'll probably just stop like full force,
just full of it's crazy.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah it's like the like road rules
or like who has the right of way?
Kind of confusing me sometimes
and okay zebra crossing.
Zebra crossings in every
country have a different meaning
and I don't know what it means in Japan.
Like so to explain in the U.K,
if there's a zebra crossing,
the pedestrian always
has the right of way.
Like you never need to fear for your life
if you're near the zebra crossing.
- You're taught to stop,
as the driver you stop
even if you see someone walking
near it, like slow down.
- Exactly, but you know
in like Southeast Asia,
zebra crossings mean nothing.
- It's a suggestion.
- It's a suggestion
(both laughing)
In Japan, I don't know
what it means either.
Sometimes they stop.
- They're supposed to
stop, but they don't.
- Others this is where I've stood like
at the front of the
several crossing, right?
When you want people to stop
and like five causes
possible, I'm like can I go?
- You have to like start
walking in the road
and then they'll stop.
So I realize I'm playing fucking chicken.
I thought I was walking
the road and be like, halt.
I have the right of way.
- Cease.
- Cease, (all laughing) My Lord.
And then go, it's weird, I
don't know why you think that,
you know, considering how
strict that road was on there
and everyone leaves so
much room between the cars,
I noticed that.
In the U--
- It's like a car's worth.
- Yeah, in the U.K it's like this much,
but in Japan it's like I
leave a car, at least to car.
- That's why I'm kind of glad
that Japan doesn't have like
roundabouts, can you imagine?
- Oh God.
- Like just how much of--
- No one would give way,
everyone would just be waiting
for someone to come in.
- No, no, don't stop, don't stop.
- Please, please go ahead
you know because there were this is like,
I don't know if it's an actual road rule
and I want to preface,
I don't know if it's an actual road rule,
but in Australia we were taught
and some people were taught,
that when you're in a roundabout right?
Usually it's like whoever's
in the roundabout first right?
It's basically like once
you're in the roundabout,
you have to give away to whoever's
in the roundabout, right?
- Yeah.
- But in Australia, some
people were taught that like
you always have to give way
to the person on your right.
And I'm just like, but then
what if this four people
at the roundabout? (laughs)
Who is gonna give way?
- It's kind of like, if you see them
and they're far enough way
on the right-hand side,
I guess go this is why I hate roundabouts,
'cause you know like super
like rock solid logic
that you can.
- Australia is the land
of fucking roundabouts.
We have a roundabout everywhere.
- We have so many in
the U.K it's kinda like
you just gotta be like,
are you Americans like
what the fucking you guys talking about?
Basically you just like kind
of have to you see a car coming
you're like, do I think I can
get this car in gear and go?
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- That just brings an
extra layer of stress
to my drive.
- The worst
- 'Cause t's like playing
a quick time event.
And if you failed a quick
time event, you just struck
you just crash.
- Crash.
- Joey drives automatic,
so he's lucky
- Oh God, yeah.
- 'Cause the worst part
is cause you obviously
have to stop versus the
time of the roundabout.
So you're like in, you're not in gear.
So you're like, you see
a car and you're like,
I've seen this car, I
have to quickly decide
whether I can get in gear and go,
(Joey laughing) And if I'm fast
enough to not make that guy
slow down too much,
'cause it's just a mess.
- Oh yeah dude,
it's easy for me 'cause I
just like, can I make it?
Yeah, of course.
- I'll just press the go pedal.
- Press the go pedal just
get in (Connor laughing)
- But yeah, I did my driving
test for a manual car, right?
And this driving test,
put me off driving manual
for my entire fucking life.
Okay to explain, I think you're allowed
16 minor offenses, right?
- 16? Oh, oh when you're taking the test.
- Minor, minor when you're driving test.
- What registers as a minor offense?
- Like not indicating?
- No, no not that's a major one.
- Maybe going a little too
early and too much time.
Stuff that doesn't matter,
but if you do a lot of them,
it would be like your shit driver.
- Stop, that one cause an accident.
- Yeah, exactly.
- So if your tires like hit a curb,
I think that's a major
- Now that's a major offense.
- So that's the level of.
- Okay, okay.
- But like a minor
offense is something that
can't cause a crash or
anything like that I think
but I got 13 on my.
- Holy shit.
- I got 13 on my driving test.
(laughing)
I thought I've failed, right?
- So I'm gonna test the limit.
- And I swear like, 'cause
I was so fucking stressed.
It was my first time driving.
It was my first attempt at
the driving test as well.
And I remember this,
there was always one road,
I was super fucking terrified
would be on my driving test.
And of course it was all my driving test.
And so driving a manual
car, it's a hill start.
- That's well.
- It's a hill start into a roundabout.
- Oh, same same.
- Oh my God,
I'm like that, I remember when I pulled up
and normally I hope that's
the roundabout fucking clear.
Of course it's not clear, you know?
So you're playing about five
different mini games at once.
And if you stop the car, if
you go too early, go too late
or do any of that shit, you fail the test.
And that like the experience
of having to drive manual
and you 'cause we've
driving manual you are
constantly playing a mini game
where I just wanna shut my brain off,
I wanna stress free driving experience.
So yeah, that's why I've
driven automatic my entire life
since then basically.
- I've never driven
automatic so long it's like
- Really?
- I'm too there.
- It'll be like fucking putting
the antenna on in Marriott.
(all laughing)
- So how do we crash?
How do I crash this?
- I'm on my way to the driving test,
I did like everything wrong.
Like I didn't indicate, I ran a red light.
I fucked up on a roundabout,
nearly close to crash.
My driving instructor was like,
it's okay if you have to do it twice.
You know it's and then I got
like two minors, that's it.
- Oh my--
- I like went in like
men mode, like focus.
I just like killed it.
I was like, wow okay damn, good at this
for this very small point during the day
where I must attempt.
- As long as it's not as bad as my uncle,
he like my uncle like he
failed his first driving test
and (laughs) you want to guess
how he failed his first driving test?
- What did he do? Did he crash?
- So like, you know when
you do you start at the DMV,
like in your driving test
or do you just started like a random road?
- We start at a random road for.
- Wherever you parked your car?
- I guess so.
So in Australia you
start at the actual DMV.
- Okay, okay.
- And you have to like
go out of the DMV driver,
come back to the DMV and then
once you're back at the DMV,
then that's the end of the test.
My uncle went out of the exit (laughs)
- No (all laughing)
- Of the DMV.
- Okay.
- So he got in the car, he started it up,
drove out two seconds later,
it was like, "you failed."
- Why?
- Because he drove out of the exit.
Sorry he dropped out of the entrance.
- That sounds better than
what happens in the U.K.
In the UK, if you do a
major, like major mistake
but you know, you've done it.
You have to complete the test.
- Oh, really?
- They don't tell you,
you failed immediately.
You just, you could like do something
and you'd know you failed.
And you still just have to
go through the entire test
knowing that you've done it.
- Oh no, because in Australia,
the moment you fail,
they just immediately tell you.
And they tell you to drive back
because to the instructor, they're like,
oh sweet we finished 15 minutes.
I can take a break.
- So they changed the U.K
tests from when you did it now.
So when I had to do it, there
was like a portion of it
that was with like a sat nav
and then there was another part
where they were like
telling me the directions,
I hated it when they were
telling me directions.
I'm like, why do I need
to be tested on this?
This is like testing my
ability to use like a quilt.
It's like, I'm never gonna
use this (Joey laughing)
Like just give me the little
robot that talks to me
and I can see where the map is.
I know what the like,
when you say right to me,
it's 10 seconds before my brain goes dumb.
It's like, right, right, right, right.
- Right now? Right now?
- Like this right.
Like my right arm this way right?
Like this my brain is like
bro when I here directions.
'Cause when I'm driving, I'm like bro
I'm trying to change gears the fuck up.
(all laughing)
- No one the testing is for
fucking backseat drivers right?
Because they like it's
all right, it's all right.
- I'm like yo, can you charge
my mix tape at least kind of.
(both laughing)
- They tell you the thoughts.
So that was pretty sick.
- I failed the test.
At least I'd wanna put the mixed tape.
- Just slip that in.
- I'll give you the mix tape
for free if you let me pass.
- It's not like hook up my
looks or something come on, man.
(all laughing)
- All right, I got you (Joey laughing)
- Stop playing all the fucking
anime openings and everything.
- Oh fuck love this
opening, I'll turn right.
- Oh my God.
- So yes, so yeah.
So now I know not to go to
the fucking DMV in Japan.
- Thank you for that.
- Thank you for taking the bullet for us.
Now we don't have to hire a
chauffeur for Trash Taste.
We just have you.
- Can't wait to go tomorrow.
(laughing)
- Yes, moving on from driving
that was a pretty big tangent,
I have an announcement, gentlemen.
- Go on.
- Like I think after 10, 12, 13 years,
I may have a new best girl of all time.
- Wow!
- Wait who was it before?
- Senjogahara, so, ever since.
- I like white bread too.
- So ever since the very first time
I've watched back
Monogatari, like Senjogahara
has been my wife for you,
you know what I mean?
She's always been the top tier girl
and like people would come close.
- (laughs) Where are you going with this?
- But no one has come
close to dethroning her.
But recently I caught up to
the rental girlfriend, Manga
and I think that she's like,
she's is in contention for
being like my best girl
of all time.
- Really?
- Yeah, which like leads
me to the question like,
when did you first know that
you have like a best girl?
'Cause I know who's yours is Joey.
- Yeah.
- And I know Connor is losing his mind.
(all laughing) At this question.
- This is like where people
were like on the forums
like how did you know you were in love?
Like what made you feel
like you were in love?
Because it's like the stomach.
- What is love? (all laughing)
- What is love and when
did you first fall in love?
- Okay, I mean, first of all,
I'm surprised Senjogahara
was like your wife
because I always thought
it was fucking Oscar.
- I mean like Oscar was someone
who I could just respect
for Connor is dying in his corner here.
- Oscar is my wife and she's
just someone I respect.
- Oscar is like 15.
- No.
- I mean, it depends.
(laughs)
- This is the biggest, no officer she's a.
- She's a drawing (Joey laughing)
- I mean I don't know if I
wanna open up that debate,
'cause that debate is a
fucking landmine of takes.
But yeah I mean like.
- We can open that up for that.
- I don't know if I want to man.
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
I'm in the worst position
for that,
(laughs) I'm in the worst
position for that argument.
- Did you know there good
defense for yourself.
- I mean, yeah but I
also don't really care.
(all laughing)
- It's like you don't need a
it's like you don't need a defense
to be like, yes, this is my girlfriend.
I don't care what you think, I love her.
- I mean, I don't think
it's like, I'm not trying
the people who are like,
yeah, it's pedophilia.
I'm like, I don't know about that.
- That's good.
- But like I think
there's gotta be something
little sauce about dude like,
yeah they're my wife who.
- I'm not gonna willingly,
you know walk into a
courtroom and being like,
here is my defense.
- Your honor, she was a drawing.
Which you know like, okay.
- Your honor I have a birth certificate.
She's technically (laughs) 900 years old.
- I do think there's a huge difference
in like having a wife and
you know like sexualizing
or whatever.
- That's true.
Okay, a wife who is like a character
who is a female I guess most of the time,
who is just really dig.
- I get that, I get that.
- Yeah, and for me it's
always been Senjogahara
just because I like from watching back
when I got three like
I love the personality
and, huh?
- Why, why?
That was the biggest huh?
- Huh, just like how
dare you even question?
- How dare you even question?
- So I can, you know think
of some excuses when I need.
- I'm just because like, I
interactions with Arararagi
were some of the most entertaining reacts,
like interactions I had seen
in anime up to that point.
I think it was like
the way she was written
and the way like it really,
what really sold me on the show
was basically Senjogahara
interaction with Arararagi
and how their romance developed
and how her character
was explored as well.
It was just something that's
like her character
really resonated with me
and I think that's what
really a waifu wears.
It's a character who really
like resonates with you
on a personal level.
Like you don't necessarily
view them as a life partner
or anything like that.
You're just like damn man.
- It's just a character
that whatever they do,
you just fucking love.
Like they can say or do anything
and just how they react
and how they are like.
- It's just like the
highest tier of Sydney.
- And I saw all of that and was like nah,
give me the one who sucks my neck.
(laughing)
Nice character development bro.
How about you suck my neck?
- Senjogahara is not my waifu,
but I fuck love her as a character.
Like I love how everything she does
and says is deadpan as fuck.
- Yeah, exactly.
- That's what I love about
- It's her deadpan
delivery and deadpan humor
which really drew her
to Mike drew her to me.
And then it was exploring
another side of the car
to a more vulnerable side,
which was made me like, okay
I'm simping i want you to be happy.
(Joey laughs) You know what I mean?
- I totally get.
- I'll take that.
- Monogatari is really
good at that though,
that's why there's so many waifus.
But now, I agree, it's like
every time like Shinobu Oshino
came on screen, like
everything she said and did
I was just like, I fucking love it.
I don't know why I can't
explain it to you in words,
I just love it.
- That powerful that when
you're done watching it,
you're like thinking about it.
- I mean, yeah, yeah, yeah,
she's such a good character.
- Have you had I've never had character,
like waifu or not like female or not
you've just like kind of resonate ways.
- You gonna have a husbando as well?
I have a husbando.
- Yeah I think so, I think so.
- I think that I can't name them (laughs)
Off the top of my head.
I don't know.
Yeah, I know like can't really
think of any immediately.
- Do you have a husbando?
- I'd have to think about it.
- 'Cause my husbando is
Usui from Kaichou Maids.
- Okay.
- So Malin is like, all
right, that's a good choice.
- Okay, what's it called in English?
- Kaichou Maids Sama is a president,
is the, is a maid, is a really
- I don't think I've seen that.
- Do want to explain this character?
- Okay, so Usui is like
the, I guess Kaichou Maids
some it's based off the shows Manga
from like the early 2000s, I believe
and the anime is from
like the early 2000s.
But basically it's the story about
like how the the school like
class president basically
is like, you know normally the anime troop
of class president is like you know,
that they're very like pure hearted,
they're very like together,
you know they're very adult
for their age kind of thing.
But this particular culture is
also a maid, at a maid cafe.
And she gets like.
- I could relate to them.
- Yeah, so basically it's like
a complete opposite, right?
And so basically she gets found out
by this like fucking honk
of a dude called Usui,
who like all the girls fucking love.
And so it's this like special relationship
where he's trying to hide the fact that
she's not actually just like altogether
like me time personality and
she fucking hates Usui for it.
But of course, with how
every show Jo Manga goes,
she's like, actually this
guy (Connor laughing)
I might like this guy and
then Usui is also like,
you know I kind started
off you know just like,
just teasing her, but she's kind of hot.
- There was a guy character
I liked what that show
where the characters whole
thing is that he's perfect
and he's a student?
- Sakamoto.
- I fucking loved that.
- I fucking love Sakamoto.
- That anime was soo good
(Joey laughing) and soo funny.
- I did not go like, that was an anime
that I heard was decent, and I was like
I didn't expect to love that,
Sakamoto
- It's so funny.
- If you haven't seen
Sakamoto it's basically like
the whole premise is that,
this guy is just the perfect human being.
- This is just the perfect guy.
- And everyone in the school
is trying to like fuck with him.
And he somehow always manages
to flip it (Joey laughing)
Like there was one time where they needed
to like make a fire in a room.
So he literally started
doing like back and forward.
- [Joey] Oh yeah (laughs)
- He goes back and forward
like jumping back and forward.
- And the friction between
his shoes starts a fire.
- And the friction starts a fire.
And it's like, what? (Joey
laughing and clapping)
I love this, I love this
man, I want fuck him.
- It's so good.
- I loved him so much.
I wish I was that cool
- Sakamoto like I'll be honest.
I didn't like it that much.
- What? It was so fun.
- Why?
- And you don't like it?
- It's because, Sakamoto
it's so pretty much like
every problem I have
with most comedy anime,
is in Sakamoto, which is, I
like the first two episodes.
And then I'm like.
- Or is it the joke too repetitive?
- They kind of doing the
same joke over and over.
- Became funnier every time
for me, I don't know why.
'Cause I knew it was coming,
it was always funny when
it got, I don't know why.
- It's like, you knew like
whatever situation it was,
it's like you knew.
- He was going to come out on top.
- He's going to solve it, but
it's the excitement of like
how we see.
- How, yeah,
the absurdity of how he
was gonna overcome it.
- I love show that because it
completely defies expectations
of like, he's probably gonna do this.
But then they just completely
flipped and be like
- Yeah, like I didn't and
there was no point in my mind
where I thought he was gonna friction
both the floor into a fire
to save all the students.
Like I didn't see that coming.
- I just wanna to work out.
(both laughing)
- And it's like, what?
It's so fun, that's like, I
love the comedy anime like that.
That'll just like, not
trying too hard, I guess.
- It's really weird,
'cause I've had the hardest
time getting into comedy anime.
- Comedy anime are normally
the worst type of anime.
- There are few comedy anime that I enjoy
and I put most of them
in the same category
as like Sakamoto where
it's funny to me like
for like one or two episodes.
And then I get bored very quickly
if they're just kind of
doing the same thing.
I always need to, like
I always need to be,
they always need to be doing
something different for me.
- What about something like Nichijou.
- Wait, wait what's a Nichijou
and also what do you think is
like the best comedy anime?
- Oh that's...
- In my opinion it's Nichijou.
- Super hard.
- Nichijou?
- Yeah.
- Like off the top of my head,
probably the hottest I've ever laughed
at a comedy anime was probably Golden Boy,
if you remember that.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- But that was most of the.
- That's an old one.
- That's a really old one.
And that's the only like
a six episode over you.
So I'd never got the chance
to get bored over there.
And it is one of the
best dubs I've ever heard
especially when it comes to a comedy anime
because you must've seen the meme
like of the one clip where it's
the guy doing the swimming.
(mumbles)
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's the one clip that
gets shared out Golden Boy.
And if you're gonna, if
you laughed at that clip,
please watch Golden Boy
because it's like every
point of Golden Boy,
I feel like is just as good as that clip.
And that was just, a one clip that
if that would sell you on that show.
- I can easily re-watch that
- Konosuba was also way funnier
than I thought it was going to be.
- Konosuba is good.
- Konosuba I've I really enjoy
in the same way I enjoy like
Always Sunny in Philadelphia
or something like that.
It's just a bunch of awful
people doing all the things.
- This anime has awful as Always Sunny.
Always Sunny it's like my
favorite fucking comedy,
I love it so much, my God.
- The corniness of a movie
as well the surprise.
What's really funny.
- I haven't watched that yet.
- Yeah, but it was also really weird
because it was really funny,
he had no one in the
cinema sloppy (laughs)
- Japanese cinemas.
- Yeah, so I felt really
bad laughing out loud.
I was just like (laughs)
- Do you ever wish that was
more like, I guess Western Humor
in comedy and cause a lot
of it does kind of feel.
- I love this very anime as comedy.
It's very like some very slapstick.
- What would classify those
as like Western comedy, right?
That's the question
- I think where...
- Biggest slapstick as
well it's any western.
- I don't necessarily
think the Japanese humor
is as slapstick as we like to point out.
I think there's a YouTube video on this
and it's like, well there's like,
I mean there's a lot of
TV shows in Japan, right?
Where like the whole
comedy is like game shows
with that like language, right?
With the
- Oh yeah,
like (mumbles) show.
- There's a bunch of
other stuff like that.
But I feel like, at least in Western,
we're like really fucking
brutal with our comedy.
You know what I mean?
Like you watch something like Always Sunny
and it's like (laughs) I couldn't imagine
anything like that coming out.
- Like Family Guy in Japan.
- It's weird though 'cause
you have the game shows here,
which go above and beyond what
we would think is acceptable.
But then when for some reason comedy
it's like they don't really
joke about that kind of stuff.
- Right.
- Right
- It's a lot of wordplay in Japan.
I feel like Japanese
companies a lot of wordplay.
- A lot of wordplay
right? But they have like
the show like fucking Orgasm Wars in Japan
where it's basically show about
if a dude can make another dude cum.
That's the whole premise.
- What?
- Whole premise, yeah.
- He recently did a video on it,
but basically the most famous
one was there was this,
it was versus this flipped
super professional Japanese
like male porn star, who can like he says
like I can control when I cum basically.
(Garnt laughing)
So he's always right,
it's a 40 minutes shoot,
all right I'll cum in the middle of it.
- I can cum in command.
- Yeah, basically, he was
like, I'm a cum in command.
Which means that if
you tell me not to cum,
I'll never cum.
And then he had to verse this guy,
- Verse? (laughing)
It wasn't verses like he
basically had to verse this guy.
He was a bartender in Shinjuku Ni-chome,
which is like the gay
district of Shinjuku,
and he's like considered to be,
he says he can make any
man cum (all laughing)
with his skills, right?
- Right.
- So basically they put him,
they put both of them in a room, right.
This is on TV by the way on National TV.
So they put him in a room
he's inside the male porn star
is like inside of a box
that's completely covered.
And the gay guy gets in basically.
And you don't see anything,
but they're both miked up.
So you can hear everything,
- How does this pass television?
(Joey laughing) how?
- And of course, you know
with traditional Japanese television
like in the corner there's like always
the reaction face (Garnt laughing)
And this is the bunch of people
just fucking losing themselves,
just watching dude suck off a gay.
- Do you mean like make
him nuts like immediately.
- He makes him not in like five minutes.
(laughing)
And the funniest part
is like, obviously like
you know watching them male porn star,
like cum on national TV.
But then we see guys coming out
and being like (speaking
in foreign language)
(all laughing)
- That's soo fucked up.
- Do you hear like the dick sucking sound?
- Oh yeah, it's on
YouTube as well, mind you.
If you look it up, I
guarantee it's on YouTube.
- It's got crazy that's
like totally acceptable.
But then like that human doesn't
or maybe not even like it's not allowed,
but they don't really find that funny.
- No, no they find it funny.
- Yeah okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
Like that was one of the most
like legendary pieces on TV.
- You find that funny,
but then why would you
reckon that something
like Sunny would be directing
that would be funny to Japanese people.
- I don't know really?
- Have you watched Sunny?
- Yeah, I've seen a bit of it.
- They probably think, man,
these people are really rude.
(both laughing)
- That's what's so funny about it.
- I don't know cause like the reason
I've really enjoyed
konosuba over something
like say Sakamoto is
that Konosuba was like
way more character-based comedy.
I very much like enjoy
character-based comedy,
where--
- Sakamoto it's just like Mr Bean.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly, exactly.
- Sorry to cut you off but.
- No, that's like the perfect analogy
where a lot of comedy anime.
- It's the perfect Bean.
- I love the comedy anime
I see it's just like,
hey, there's this one joke and it's funny
like the first few times
let's see how far we can stretch it.
But eventually, I'm gonna get bored.
Whereas with a lot of like, you
know, sitcoms and everything
like that, you know, it's a
lot of character-based comedy
where you know, some of the
best moments are seeing,
how knowing the characters
and seeing how they
interact with each other.
And you know, that's what
the comedy builds off of.
You talked about Nichijou,
I haven't actually seen Nichijou yet.
- You haven't seen Nichijou?
- I haven't, it's been like the one anime
the one common anime.
- I know you've, do you love Sakamoto?
you've fuck love Nichijou.
'Cause Nichijou is that one comedy anime
where every joke is expectation defining.
- 'Cause one thing I
will say about Nichijou
is that it doesn't seem like
it's not a character-based comedy as it?
- Every clip I've seen
looks like funny as far.
- But the thing that sells him on like,
what makes me really want
to watch Nichijou is that
every clip I've seen is vastly different
and vastly like they
have an original approach
to a joke every time
whether it be like animation
of the punchline or something.
So I would probably really
enjoy Nichijou as well.
- Yeah, Nichijou is interesting
because I feel it's kind of half,
it's like halfway between
Sakamoto and Konosuba,
in the sense that it's a lot like Sakamoto
where like all the jokes are very,
you know, expectation
defining and stuff like that.
But as you're watching these
like short clips of like,
because it's basically
just a bunch of short jokes
put into one episode essentially.
But the way that they do it,
the way that it's written,
is that like each characters
like development is you know,
very physically defined.
So by the end of like the 20
something episodes in Nichijou,
you know exactly what
these characters like.
So there is character development
and character comedy within it as well.
Which I think is what
makes it especially funny
where like the more episodes you watch,
the more you start to understand,
okay, this character is like this
and this character is like this.
So I can expect some
kind of joke like this
but then the writing's
like, no fuck all of that,
that you thought you were gonna expect,
we're gonna give you something
completely different.
And that's what makes it so funny.
And of course it's Kyoto Animation.
So, you know--
- I've been meaning to
watch it like forever.
- I've seen the dead scene, the dead scene
in so many times every
time I fucking lose money.
Like there are so many
layers to that one scene.
It just makes me want to watch Nichijou.
- And especially after, when
I helped your film the video
with the interview,
with the one of the main group's actress.
- Oh, Honda Mariko,
yeah.
- Yeah,
and she was super chill and nice.
- Yeah, she was the voice of Yugo.
- And I felt bad cause I'm like,
I wish I could appreciate.
Being in front of you more but.
- It was crazy because all regular voice
is literally Yugo.
It's like I'm talking to Yugo
But yeah, it's fucking hilarious.
I mean I'm sure people can agree
but that's the good thing
about Nichijou, right?
Is that like unlike Konosuba
where you kind of have
to like understand the
story and the characters.
It's very, I feel it's really hard
to like watch a Konosuba
scene out of context
and still be fine.
- Yeah, yeah I would agree with you
'cause it's the characters
that have been built up.
- Right, you need to
understand the characters,
but Nichijou somehow
there is characters in it
but they've somehow established the joke
where you can just watch a
clip completely out of context
and still fucking hilarious.
- Because okay, like to
counter off that point
that's the other show that I can think of
where I got kind of bored
quite fast was a Pop Team Epic
which you know,
(both laughing)
unfortunately, sorry Joey,
nothing to do with you
- No, no it's okay.
- I heard you on the Ratio
Joey (Garnt laughing)
I turned that shit off immediately.
- It wasn't funny, try again.
- Like Pop Team Epic was great
until I realized that not every.
- Not funny.
- No, no there not every clip was funny.
And like, and then I
realized that the optimal way
to watch Pop Team Epic was just
to watch like the YouTube compilations.
And so I realized that, hey,
I could spend 10 minutes
or you know, 20 minutes if
you wanna watch both versions
or I could spend like
five, three to five minutes
just watching the best.
- I hated how I played twice.
- Yeah, that shit was weird.
- It was okay for one episode.
But I was like, oh, we're doing that
oh we're doing it every episode.
- Every time, yeah.
I mean, I can, you know,
having been in the anime,
I can confidently say a
lot of it wasn't funny.
(Both laughing)
A lot of was just really
stupid in my opinion.
- It was very like.
- Except the episode I was in
that was fun (all laughing)
- That's was a banger.
- That's was in the top 10
anime episodes of all time,
like come on.
- It was like way too much
Ha Ha XD internet humor,
like insulate Meme Humor.
A lot of the times I would
say the one comedy anime
that I'd say pulled that off well
but this is going back way back.
I don't know if you guys
have heard of this anime
called Cromartie High School.
- Yeah, I have.
- That's like a really, really old anime
that kind of predicted a lot
of internet and Meme Humor
way before way before
this was like prevalent
in like our culture.
And I remember the one clip
that's made me watch the
entire thing was it was,
I can't remember when it came out
but it was like early 2000, it was like
2002 or something.
- Something like that.
- And it was like
parodying internet trolls
and stuff like that.
And like the early 2000s
something like this,
this is fucking brilliant.
It was so ahead of his time.
I don't know if it has
aged badly or not badly,
I haven't really watched it in a while,
but that was also something where the dub
was fucking brilliant as well.
- I remember reading the
Manga at a friend's place
and I've never laughed
so hard reading a Manga.
- What's an anime that was funny
purely because it was just
so fucking awful and like.
- I mean there's a lot,
that's my entire career
Just watching bad anime and laughing.
- I watched King's Gamefor the first time,
I fucking lost it, I couldn't
stop laughing as shit.
- No, no King's Game was bad
and then there was the dub.
Was just made it,
- I didn't watch the dub, is it bad?
- I felt so bad cause it
was obvious that like,
you know it wasn't on their priority.
(Joey laughing)
It was rough dude, it was rough.
- That's a really shame as well
because like when I've heard
that the King's Game anime,
I was like fucking horrible.
I was like, oh man, I kind
like the Manga though.
So it's like really a shame
that the anime just like
completely fucked it.
- I can't remember
trying watch two episodes
where I was like, I've seen
enough, I'm just satisfied.
Like I was just like fucked
dude, this is fucking awful.
- A thing to see that burst out
or burst a laughing out was
I think there was a challenge
where the guy had to sleep with the girl
or something like that.
And it's the girl is like
the main guy's girlfriend
or crush I can't remember what it was,
but so it's his best friend
who has to sleep with this girl
who is the main characters girlfriend.
I'm just gonna say girlfriend now.
And so he doesn't wanna do it,
he doesn't want to betrays bro like that.
So the main character is
trying to fucking argue
with this guy to sleep
with his girlfriend.
(both laughing)
And so he refuses, so what
he does, this his solution
is to fucking deck the guy in
the until he turn conscious
and then the guy he tells
who is girlfriend in the dub
and just do it while
he's unconscious, please.
And I'm just like.
- Oh my God (Joey laughing)
- It is soo bad, my God.
Are you sharing any anime?
You think of the top rack?
- Oh, my God, I mean
I've been meaning to like
make a series on my channel
where I'd do exactly that
where it's take the worst
anime and I just love that.
Like I don't know a lot of the,
like the most horrible
ones are like obviously
the ones that no ones of fucking horrible.
- [Connor] True, true, true.
So like, I don't know,
what's the famous one?
Like Skelter Heaven is a famous one.
Mass Destruction is a famous one,
you have seen any of those?
- No.
- You have seen any of those?
- I still haven't seen Mass Destruction.
- Mass Destruction.
- Skelter Heaven sounds
familiar, I don't know why.
- Yeah, Skelter, it's
like one of the worst
written anime basically.
Eiken's another worse written anime.
- Oh no Eiken.
- I Fucking Eiken is so bad.
- Oh my God.
- I love it.
But yeah I mean fucking
some videos on them all,
but like those ones make sense, all right?
Because it's like, of
course no one knows them,
they're fucking horrible, right?
But I'm trying to think like
what's like a well known anime?
- That's bad.
- That's like horrible.
Like it's cause it's well
known because it's bad.
- Because like the only one I can think of
is this anime called Garzey's Wing,
Which is I would say it's
less that's less famous
and more infamous.
I'd say like the most other infamous one
is probably the Ghost Stories dub maybe.
- I mean if we're gonna
bring up Ghost Stories.
We might as well talk about it.
- Okay Ghost Stories dog.
- It's fucking legendary.
- My favorite fucking dog.
- I'll never gonna get
anything like that ever again.
- So we never will because do you know
the story behind how that stuff?
- Yeah, yeah, I know, a lot about it.
- Why don't you explain it
for people who don't know.
- Basically Ghost Stories is,
okay what is the actual
plot of the show? (laughs)
- Kids go into an
abandoned school building,
find ghosts trying resolve.
- Isn't just their school
building, it's like
there just ghosts and they have to use.
- No, no there is talking abandoned
side of the building, right?
It's like the main building
and then there's the abandoned.
- Who the fuck freaking pays attention?
- I paid attention (Joey laughing)
- That they basically
have to get rid of ghosts.
- Yeah, basically.
- Basically it's the story doesn't matter.
What matters is the dub, as
it's considered one of the best
or the best worst dub of all time
or the worst best dub of all time.
- Yeah, it's weird 'cause online
it's seems to be like people can't agree
if it's like good or bad
and I can't understand how.
- It's funny.
- It's the room of anime basically.
- So basically what
happened is this was a show
that sold so poorly when aired in Japan,
that when they sold the licenses,
they just basically told the licenses,
do whatever you want with
this show to make it sell.
Like we don't care, you have all creative,
you have all creative control.
And so basically they just
chip posted in the dub.
It's often like seen as the
very first Abridged Series
because it's basically what happens
if a bunch of official doubles
just basically fanned up
and originally show and fuck about.
And it's one of the
most infamous like dubs
that has ever been released.
- I can't like, the one the
puppet kills me every time,
he's like the little, the younger Brother,
and his entire lifetime,
he's just going, yay, yay.
(all laughing)
Like his mouth moving.
But the dog was just like,
I'm gonna make you cry in every line.
- This is a really good video
about it by a cartoon type.
I can't remember if it
did sell badly or not?
I know that's the common thing,
but I swear there was some point
where that actually wasn't
the case and it did do well.
I can't remember exactly
the story, but again, yeah.
Cartoon Ciphers are really great
like 30 minute video about this whole dub.
They spoke to top sources,
it's really good video.
It's just a really unique dub and also,
because of how they recorded it,
normally when you record anime,
whoever goes in first is
like the first to record.
So basically they all
wanted they go in first
so they could like start the improv scene.
- [Hosts] Right, right, right.
- So everyone to play off of went first.
So they were all trying to get in first,
it was just interesting because
when you're watching it,
you know that you're like,
I wonder who started.
- This scene.
- Yeah, because even if they spoke first
doesn't mean they were the
one who recorded first.
So it's fun to try and figure out,
I wonder who fuck started
the shit joke basically.
But it's just such a fun dub
and if you, I just watched it all.
- Oh yeah I've seen it all.
- Yeah, I've seen it all.
- Yeah, it's so fun.
I really wish that we
could get something again
but we're never gonna get anything.
- Yeah, yeah, it's.
- Different times.
- It's different times now.
I'm sure some of the jokes
that was ended up probably
would not be able to have
like we couldn't get away
with in this day and age.
- Oh God, no. God, no.
- But it's just such like a
timestamp for that time period.
And it's just basically all improv as well
which is kind of funny how some,
it's like some of the jokes
I thought were very good
and the fact that it
wasn't scripted at all
and it was just all improv,
I'm just like man this,
I still think it's funny to this day.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- Even though it might be slightly,
you know not politically correct.
- It's definitely not politically correct.
- Like the Robot scene.
- I was so sad that I would
never hear that voice again.
His laugh,
(laughs)
his funny little requests.
- Touch me.
- His reprimands.
- Touch me harder.
(Both laughing)
- It's wait, what was the joke
about that rabbit were like
it's deadly is so something?
- No, it was like the,
- I can't get with you.
It's not because you're a rabbit
it's because you're black.
- Oh my God!
- Do you remember that one?
- (both laughing) Is
that a joke? Oh my God.
- Yeah it's a joke.
And then the rabbit,
like in the flashback,
the rabbit is like
talking in the flashback.
He's like touch me harder.
- Oh yeah, right, right, right.
Yeah, you'd never get away with that now.
I think there's also back then,
like there was money in it
but the money levels scale
is like very different.
And I think a lot of the
dubbing is focused more
on the big shows.
- But aside from dubs like what is like
universally considered like,
this show is just kind of sucks
and it's just not very good.
It could be objective really bad,
like we can be talking like
- This is gonna be like
hot takes though now like,
Is now watch Trash Taste,
is all about.
- I don't know.
I can't decide if the reason
I thought Higurashi was shit,
is because I watched it didn't dub.
- That's definitely the
reason why we share.
- 'Cause I thought the show kind of sucked
after like episode two.
I was like, wow, this is
really fucking boring.
Is it like that normally?
Is it boring after episode two
or is that because of the dub?
- No it's really picks up like
near the end, in my opinion.
- And again, this is
when I watched Higurashi
when I first started watching animation,
this is nearly like.
- Also you've been tainted by the dub.
- Yes.
- I mean,
we talked about the dub
the other day very briefly.
- It will say I've just
recently watched Higurashi
for the first time and
I watched it dubbed.
(both laughing)
And it was a hilarious
watch at times because.
- It's bad, bad.
- Higurashi dub is really
bad and it's not like,
it's not the kind of bad where it's awful,
that he can laugh at.
It's just, there's one good voice,
I guess, I think.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- And everyone else has just pretty bad.
- Which character is this?
- I think it's Shion.
- What color is her hair?
That's how I remember (laughs)
- [Hosts] Green.
- Yeah, yeah (all laughing)
- She is one that did the screaming,
a lot of the screaming, right?
I remember that was pretty good.
- I've seen the dub scene where she like
does the maniacal screaming.
I'm like, and I looked at
that clip and I'm like,
the dub must be all right.
- There is lot of people who
when the new show was announced
were like I hope you'll
bringing back the old cast
and I'm like, I hope they
don't it remember that,
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Why would you want?
- I think that meant the Japanese cast.
- They dubbed it well.
- Oh, really?
- People are saying,
when they saw the Japanese one,
they wanted to bring it back.
- Why?
- It was announced they
wanted to bring it back
they were like, because
there's an argument to be made
where it's like, the actors
are probably better now
and the stuff it's also like (hissing)
yeah sometimes they just recasting,
get a new slate.
- I mean, if they are going to bring back
the original cast please,
like have a real auditioning
you know, (Joey laughing) like
please like make them audition
because, you know the quality of dubbing
is I'd say a lot better now.
- [Connor] It's much better.
- Compared to back then
there were definitely
some very, very good dubs,
but it was definitely
a much larger spectrum
than you get now, I mean (both laughing)
- Some of the dubs that
came out after Cowboy Bebop
is like, this came at the
same time, oh okay, oh no.
- I remember when, back in the day
when it was like every
doubles like mediocre to shit
and then there was Cowboy Bebop.
And everyone just pointed a Cowboy Bebop
as the golden child to be like,
not all dubs are bad.
We got Cowboy Bebop. (Connor laughing)
- It was like the DiCaprio
and then (both laughing)
- I think it's well even
people who like I think,
Brice Patin, I don't know if this is true.
I was told this it's a lot of the actors
even though they were the voice
and there was no problem with
the voice and it's great,
they still have to audition
again for season two,
just to make sure they still there.
- Just to make sure they still got it.
- Just to make sure--
- I think, I heard that's true.
I mean, I'm happy to be corrected on it
but that's what I was told.
- But yeah I mean, I thought, I mean
it might've been because
I watched the dub as well
but I just didn't care.
- It was kind of shit right?
- Why would you do that
to yourself though?
- Okay this is back.
Okay, I don't know your
100% did not have this face.
- Of course not (all laughing) but,
when I first got into anime,
I only watched up
because I came from like.
- No that's understandable.
- Right, I was like, I'm not used to it.
I rarely, I only do it once
every while for a foreign film
that everyone says is like amazing.
I have to watch them, I have
to watch them talk French,
fine you know, I don't like doing that,
(laughs) get excited.
But you know for a very
long time I watched only dub
and the show happened to be
one of the top rated shows
and I watched the dub, but it was shit
and then I just moved on with my life.
And then obviously later on down the line,
a show comes out that you're like,
I really wanna watch the
show it's available in sub,
you make an exception
and then suddenly everything
becomes the exception
and you start watching only sub.
It's kinda I think a lot of
anime fans go through that
where they wanna watch dub if possible.
And I kind of know 'cause
I'm like you'll come around.
You will 'cause there'll be
that one show that's coming out.
They'll be like, all right,
Demon Slayer episode 19.
Everyone said it was
hype, yes I'm watching.
- Now I whenever I get the chance,
I watched Dubbed all
the time because this,
because there's --
- Come full circle.
- This is a chance where I can watch dub,
I like a lot less than
just me watching sub.
So if it's probably, you know,
like if it's on Netflix or something,
I'm probably gonna wait for the dub
like I did for the Great Pretender.
Cause I was like I knew I
could watch it on Netflix
in Japanese with subtitles,
but I wanted to wait for it to be dubbed
so I could enjoy it in a different time.
- I could not express my
disappointment in the dub.
When they dubbed it like
multilingual to begin with.
So when they speak in Japanese,
they speak in Japanese
and when they speaking English,
they were speaking English.
- Right, right, right.
- Only for the first 10 minutes.
And then they just cut, they
put a note on screen saying,
all right back to normal.
- Yeah, they did that in the Subla
as well.
- Yeah, as well.
But like, why?
- Just because I guess, because in the sub
for the first 10 minutes, it
was the most God awful English,
that I've ever heard.
- Yeah, yeah.
And I was like, thank God it's a Japanese.
- The French guy was okay.
- The French guy was fine but.
- The Japanese guy sounded like I mean,
here's the thing right?
- The Japanese guy was
like, I've done Duolingo,
that's what it sounded like.
- He sounded pretty bad.
But also (laughing)
like what have you said,
people speak English here.
I don't mind it because when
I heard the Japanese people
speak broken English, I was like,
yeah, that sounds right, yeah cool.
- Can you enjoy the entire
series as much hearing that?
- I would not be able to enjoy the series.
- I would not be able
to like immerse myself.
There's a difference between like.
- I don't give it's almost more immersive
that he's speaking to me in
broken (laughing) English.
- I mean, it's possibly too
immersive (Connor laughing)
Just like I can't imagine like.
- I don't want that kind of immersion.
- I can't imagine him being like.
- The Anime..
- I can't imagine like a top play like.
- The French guy was so good
though he had a French accent.
- The first guy was good,
but I can't imagine like a class A actor,
like scamming all these people
with that like broken
English you know what I mean?
I just.
- Give me all your money.
- But it's like sometimes in you know,
when you watch a Hollywood movie,
though they might have like not a main,
but like a side character
is pretty prominent
who could speaks broken
English and that's fine.
- I don't like it though.
- Why aren't you like it?
- Cause it's broken.
- But they're trying their
best to learn English.
(laughing)
- But, they're not like, they
never like the main character
or the main focus.
- I guess, I don't know
there was something
that was really like
refreshing about hearing a guy
with a Japanese accent,
who clearly was Japanese,
speak fluent like Japanese
then go to English.
Even though, I guess they
were speaking mainly.
- Because if you have, if
you gonna have the show that
where they speak mainly English,
then why not just re-dub it so it's,
you know it's.
- So it's fully English.
- Yeah, I'm sure there
was actors out there
who sounded Japanese, but were
like native quality English.
- Right, right.
that could have been Ken Watanabe, right?
- Someone are like Ken Watanabe's level
definitely would've worked.
- I love the French guy though,
I love the fucking fake French.
- If we could get that
level of, what's the word,
I'm looking for?
Multi
- Multilingual.
- Multilingual
- Fluency, I don't know.
- Multilingual fluency.
I'm sure (laughs)
- That's term (both laughing)
That's the term that we
definitely didn't just coin.
- I know there's a term for it.
I'm just joined out.
- I don't fucking know.
I have no fucking, don't look at me.
- Multilingual fluency.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I get what you mean but don't worry.
I get what you're saying.
- 'Cause you know, like if
you know like Hollywood films,
you always expect when
someone's from that country
that they come from that
country and like, yeah okay,
the budget is not even
in the same ballpark.
But I think it's doable.
I would actually wouldn't have minded
The Grip Tender with the
broken English the whole time.
- I mean it there is a
level of broken English
I would find except for
one that was not like,
I would just be like
laughing half the time
(Connor laughing)
- Yeah, it's so you know,
I love Ken Watanabe,
but I don't think I'd be
able to watch an entire movie
where 90% Ken Watanabe talking.
- I could his English is amazing.
- Ken's English I feel it's good enough.
- It's good, but like even then
it's like cutting close with me
and like the English in Great Pretender
was like no way near that level.
- I guess yeah, I'm sure
there's actors out there,
Japanese who living LA,
who could have like probably have done it.
- Yeah, of course.
- But did they have the budget for it?
I mean, what's wrong with anime.
- It just felt like,
this was the perfect show to
really try and pull that off.
Just kind of disappointed.
- Also I think it's because like,
to most Japanese audiences
or watching Great Pretender
that level of broken English is like,
damn this boy can speak English.
(both laughing)
Wow, it's basically fluent.
- I'm sure Japanese side would have also
like to have maybe heard
the same thing, right?
Why would the English people
trying to speak the Japanese
sounding somewhat competent,
I don't know, amazing.
- Yeah, maybe I don't know,
there might've been like a
slight like racism problem
though involved in that right.
Even though it's really not racism,
but you know people always
throw that out right.
Think, like or they
speaking in a funny accent
must be racist.
- Yeah, I feel like the rules
do work a bit differently
from like live action film to you know,
dubbed you know and voice
acting and stuff like that.
Because the expectation
isn't that you can get
like a multilingual cast it's that,
there's like one spoken language
and we should speak
that one spoken language
and everything else is
like it can be possible.
- I guess like yeah when you watch,
what's a movie with
like multiple languages.
I guess because if it
has multiple languages,
you wouldn't follow right?
- Inglourious Basterds
I guess yeah you wouldn't
need a dub right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, I guess that makes sense.
- Yeah, I mean in Inglorious bastards,
they you know they put subtitles, I think
when they speak different languages?
- Hard coded on the movie.
- Yeah, in movie, yeah.
- I know, ,cause I
watched a movie recently
that was about like World War II.
Also really fucking awkward
being the only white guy
in like a World War II movie
about like the Japanese
being like destroyed.
I was just sitting there
and like my seat like this,
like I'm American.
- Just waving the flags.
(both laughing)
- 'Cause like you know, like
when the, if I can like,
there was like the planes
were being bombed and shit.
and I'm like, do I like feel happy
that the Japanese go like whooped here?
Are they happy, are they
like, damn those Americans.
They got us, it was weird.
(Joey and Connor laughing)
I didn't know like what
the vibe is in the cinema.
(All laughing)
- Considering have we talked
about that time we watched,
what's that film?
Fukushima
- 50
- Fukushima 50.
So that we.
- Holy Joey wasn't there.
- I wasn't there.
- Okay, is it called Fukushima 50?
- Yeah, Fukushima 50.
- So there was this film
that was made in Japan
about the whole Fukushima tragedy.
- And it's like how to couch.
So we got invited to like
a private screening of it.
So we got an early copy of it.
- To give our thoughts to them.
- And you know, the whole
film, you know it's.
- Ken Watanabe is in it,
it's fucking amazing.
- Ken Watanabe is in it.
- Fucking great.
- Yeah I've got you.
- There's you know, I'd rate
it a good like six out of 10,
there was some really good moments
and then there were some
really boring moments.
And then there were these moments in it
where they focused on
these American characters
and the like the American military,
who wanted to you know
he wanted to help Japan.
And for one, some of them
weren't even American.
There was this like.
- They're like South Africans
- Yeah, there is one African dude in it.
- They were like South African
in this American military boardroom
and he sounded didn't even
try to fucking hide it.
He sounded like such a fix (all laughing)
And it's not a like a
light accent South Africa,
it's really fucking for long.
And I was just so
confusing and yeah, go on.
- I can't remember the exact line,
but there was this one, do
you remember the exact line?
- I do, I do.
- Okay do you wanna
explain the exact line?
- I'm actually paraphrasing,
but it was roughly something like.
- So there okay to explain the scene
before he says the line.
So it was so obviously the
Fukushima emergency was happening
and the Americans were like
discussing how to help,
help the Japanese and how to provide aid
and stuff like that.
- All these scenes were shot like,
so the Japanese scenes
were shot like perfect,
the cinematography was on point.
And then it cut to like
a fucking sit-com quality
looking camera cuts.
He looked really shit and then
the act is opened their mouth
and you're like oh fuck.
And imagine a script right?
Of how Japanese people think
that American people talk about the war.
That's the only way I can
describe how the Americans spoke,
because it was like, the
one line was like, when it,
like it blew up, actually to
the Americans they were like
men, you think they would have learned
how to handle nuclear
technology after we nuked them?
(both laughing)
And I was like the line and
we all looked at each other,
like you just say that, what the fuck?
(laughing)
- Like we were in like this
like private screening.
We looked around, it was
me, Connor, Sydney and Malin
and then every like just
Japanese businessmen.
And the Japanese businessmen
were like fully immersed,
they were quiet and we're like,
yeah this is not American speak.
And I was looking around
a Connor, Sydney and Malin
and we were just all like.
- Like Joey's like.
- What the fuck did we just here?
(all laughing) Is this okay?
- I'm like what? They
can't say that, can they?
it was just so bad
and I was just so bad, so bad.
- And then just like to imagine the
fucking South African guy
and be like, I agree with
everyone in this room right now.
- South African guys said it.
(all laughing)
And there's just every time it was like,
please don't cut to the Americans,
please don't cut to the America
don't cuts the fucking American
- He was just like an 80 SIMCOM,
it's already fucking right
and they had like this
flashback scene as well,
with this one character,
there's one American general
who had no play in the plot or whatever
had zero screen time and
then they just randomly
cuts to a flashback of him in Japan.
And I'm like, why is this in the film?
- And then like towards the end,
there's just the shot of
like the Americans coming
and giving water bottles to them
and it's like, all right sick.
I'll take a bottle of heavy in hell I do.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Just been nuked, but
thanks for the water bro.
(all laughing)
- This will really save
us, thanks America.
(all laughing)
- Like if that line was
in an American film.
- Oh my God.
- The fucking shit storm.
It would start.
- Yeah, that's the thing
bro, it's okay 'cause it's
written like, I assume,
it was written by a Japanese and outsource
to like an American company on a budget,
I'm fucking guessing.
- American like outsourcing
was like we have to translate this?
(both laughing)
Are we lancing, is this is right?
- It was fine, I just
try not to go to films
where Japanese the bad guys,
I've kind of learned my lesson.
- Yeah, it's brutal.
- Yeah, I thought I
was gonna watch Tenant,
but it turned out it was just a war movie.
I genuinely got the wrong
tickets (laughs) the wrong thing.
I paid for the wrong tickets.
I wanna watch Tenant, I did watch Tenant,
really good by the way.
Watch it, yeah it's basically.
- I wanna watch that as well.
- It's like Inception, but
more mind fuck I think.
- Really?
- Anyway, what we talking about?
- We talking bad anime
and we go on another turn.
- Why do they talk about the cinema?
- I don't know.
- I don't fucking know about it.
- Everyone can scroll back.
- We can't do that though.
- Yeah, everyone's gonna
be like, it's so obvious.
I don't know what you're
talking about please everyone.
Higurashi right? Or some shit.
- That's right.
- We were talking about Higurashi.
- How you guys willingly...
- The actors pretending--
- I mean, I would like, I'm going to watch
the remake of Higurashi in Japanese.
'cause the reason I watched in Japan
was 'cause like you know.
I'm gonna re-watch in Japanese
anyway, it's on Netflix,
I might as well watch it.
I thought he was an okay time,
honestly I was paying half
attention half the time.
- [Connor] You know.
- Because I was fucking
doing arc nights roles,
I don't fucking remember.
- (Joey laughing) Keeping
his priorities straight.
- I watched an episode of Anohana again,
kind of thought of shit.
I've watched all of Anohana, and I agree.
- I was looking at you to be like
don't you dare I finish the sentence sir,
don't drop the eSports
- It was kind of shit.
- I watched Anohana like three years ago
and I fucking bawled my
eyes out, great time.
I watched to the episode
one again I'm like, wow,
I stuck at this episode.
- Nothing happens in episode one.
- Yeah, that's why shit.
- Episode one was by far the
worst episode of Anohana.
The episode one of Anohana of
almost put me off of Anohana.
- That makes it kind of shit bro.
- 'Cause I thought when it first started,
I thought he was like some
Lolly fan service Baits.
'Cause I remember seeing
where men must sit on his lap
and I'm like, (Joey laughing)
here we fucking go again.
- The guy is like fuck, here we go again.
(all laughing)
- I was just like, another
Lolly bait Fan Service show.
And then I think it was
like halfway through episode
like there all like the
end of episode two or three
where I actually got emotionally invested.
I remember episode one
was like pretty bad.
- Do you think if Anohana came out today,
it would be given the same level
of respect that it's given?
I don't think you could hold to it.
- I don't think so because at the time
that Anohana came out,
there were very few shows
that went in that direction.
- Right, right.
I feel like and especially with
like how short the show was,
like it managed to do
something in 12 episodes
that a lot of anime struggled
to do in late 20 plots.
- That's right they were like kind anime.
Now if you go watch it
back, I don't think.
- Okay, to be fair that you
only watched episode one, right?
- Yeah, I didn't watch it all again,
I watched just episode one again.
- Well then that's probably
why you thought it shit
because you watched the worst episode.
- But after I watched it,
I was like how the did I make it
to episode two after I watched
this? 'Cause it was shit.
- Yeah, but that's the
same as like every person
who watches like the first
episode of Steins Gate
and it's like, why would
I continue to watch it?
- Episode one of Steins Gate
is good, right? I think.
- I think it was a little boring.
- I don't remember.
- I remember thinking.
- I was looking outside half the time,
I don't fucking remember anything.
(all laughing)
- For some reason with anime like I do.
- Why did you start to re-watch it?
- 'Cause it was Emirichu,
Emirichu she told me,
she thought it was shit
and I thought no, it's
good right, it's good.
So I went back and rewatched it.
- Yeah, but I guarantee Emily also
only watched episode one
and was like, it's shit.
- No, she watched all of that, she said,
but she watched it recently.
- Oh, well then.
(all laughing)
- Common and defend yourself, Emily
- I've watched Anohana and
felt like, four times I think.
- Four times?
- Yeah.
- I've only rewatched it
once and I thought it was so.
- We'd have flying cars by now,
people stop rewatching
anime this many times,
are you fucking kidding?
Four times why?
- Because I remember I think Anahona
was the very first anime
that got me to cry.
'Cause I remember back and
forth before I watched Anahona,
I was like stone-faced, I
can never cry during anime.
- And she like this watching.
- I ain't no bitch.
- I'm a real man
and then like a bitch the
first time I watched Anahona.
And like after I watch Anahona,
it was so fucking long before
I could find like other shows
that I could, you know
bring a tear to my eye.
I tried watching Clannad, that
just didn't fucking happen.
- I mean it's so easy to make me cry,
like I feel like just the right beeps
and boops will make me cry right.
- You find one good dub
person and you're like.
I love this beeps and boops.
- You're soo beautiful.
- Yes, so like the reason I
re-watched it so many times
was whenever I felt like I
just need a good cry right now.
But so I would just put
on Anahona just to like,
get just get those emotions out.
- It takes you that much to get a cry out?
(Joey laughing)
- Before I can.
- Can you not just like do
it just like on command?
- No.
- Okay, if I'm fit.
(laughing)
I didn't know I put that
there, Malin is like what? So.
(Connor laughing)
I've got to prepare myself,
that's how I was spilling tears.
That's how I do it on Quebec.
No, so if I feel like I need to cry,
like as you say you feel
like you need to cry, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I need that push, I need
to like listen to that song
or I watch the anime.
- I pretty much replicate
what that guy did
in the best cry ever video of like that.
(mimicking crying)
I basically like just
sit there and I'm like.
(mimicking crying)
(all laughing)
And then once you get it started,
it like goes you know for like 30 seconds.
- But, does that feel
the same as like normal?
- You can watch a fucking KFC
commercial and start crying.
(laughing)
If I'm in the right mood, honestly yeah.
If it's like an emotional soundtrack to it
like I could get it.
'Cause the thing is right it's like Wank.
(laughing loudly)
It's just a different type of Wank, right?
And my mind I'm like they both feel
the exact same when you've done it.
Like when you cry, it feels
like a relief, when you wank.
- Have you ever cry wanked?
(all laughing)
- I don't dare try to mix the two.
- You know how easy this is for you.
- He hasn't read metamorphosis.
(all laughing)
- Read more metamorphosis
you'll know the definition
of a cry wank.
(all laughing)
- When you do that cry without urge,
do you not feel like when you
stop crying you're like, ah.
- No that's why we put
it on because before that
I just couldn't cry.
- How's the whole process
take to make you cry?
How many episodes do you wanna
watch for you start crying?
(Connor laughing)
- I mean so.
- Lemme skip to the right path.
- Okay, so if we go beyond just
re-watching the entire thing,
sometimes I would just like,
if I needed a quick cry
like if I needed like a five minute wank
or whatever I'm like a cry WanK,
I would just put on the
final episode, I'd be like
- Wait, wait you just said cry wanked
to the ending of Anahona.
- No, no (Joey and Connor hamming)
- Using the same analogy.
If I needed that, like quick set, like.
- Skip the blow job right.
(Connor laughing)
- Go right to penetration.
- Yeah, just straight into tears,
you go to like the fucking end of Anahona.
If I needed like the
full buildup or anything,
if I had like a whole day to waste
and I was just fell If I just
felt emotional the entire day
if I just had a shit day and
I just needed to cry it out,
I just re-watch Anahona.
- I was about to say like,
I had kind of imagine
someone being like fuck
I need to cry or I tell
time to invest six hours
into this year.
- I just feel like you
say no or something like.
(Joey laughing)
How did you start crying man?
- Okay, I completely like relate to the,
if I need to cry, then
like a good song will do
that to me instantly.
Like I know, I have like a list,
immediately I'm just saying, I know
if I put this song on.
- Men need to cry more.
I know the exact timestamp
as to where the tears will start coming.
- Men should start, men should cry more.
- I feel like men should cry more
like once I discovered Anahona,
I was on a fucking mission
to find my next anime
that could make cry.
- That next time.
- Yeah, it was because I don't know,
I've always had like trouble crying
or show my emotion like
publicly or whatever.
For some reason like watching,
like the saddest thing could
happen to me IRL right?
I just don't cry, I don't
know why like for example,
like I fucking love my grandmother, right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And I thought this entire time when I,
you know when she passed away
and I went to her funeral,
but I couldn't shed some tears.
I for some reason I just
couldn't shed tears,
even though I knew I cared about her.
Like I loved her as like family
and like one of the person I like.
- But that's a thing like,
you don't have to like,
show that emotion,
express it like you know
outside to feel it right?
- But for some reason, watching
a good scene in an anime
or watching that one anime
that just brings it out.
That just gets it out full me.
- I think it's feels like
it feel safe at home, right?
Like you feel like, all right,
I can be vulnerable, right?
I can do this here.
- Can you cry in front
of other people though?
- Yeah.
- I can't.
- When I'm in a movie with someone,
doesn't matter who it is, if
it's fucking sad, I'll be like.
- Are you one of those
people who like watches
like something really emotional on a plane
that you can cry on a plane?
- I can cry on a plane.
(all laughing)
I think I have cried
on the plane (laughing)
I'm like fucking you checking out.
(all laughing)
- 'Cause I'm definitely one
of those people who are like,
if I watch, 'cause I watch Maki on a plane
and I fucking cry like basically on,
but I had to like really just
strain my eyes and be like.
I cannot show weakness to
the person sit next to me.
- I think it's a
subconscious thing for me.
'Cause if there's other people around,
like there are sometimes
that I want to cry,
I want to cry
and it just sometimes when
there's someone else there
I just lose like froze for a split second,
I lose the immersion and then I'm like,
ah, I got to build up
myself like the tears,
have to build up again.
And it's crying hard for me, I don't know.
I value it whenever
something does make me cry,
which is why I've really
value for example your name.
Because that was the only time
I've ever cried in a cinema
with other people around me.
But that was less because
it was sad and more
because there's like,
there's just so many emotions
right now, this is beautiful,
(Connor laughing) I just
have to let it out somehow.
- I'll go on, I was on a train
and I was on the Yamanote
Line or something.
I was watching a video
and it's actually about
like they in Japan, they have
like cinemas to make men cry.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, I saw that.
And so I was watching
this video about like,
where they make basically,
they just Cry Porn to a bunch
of Japanese businessman.
And it was kinda like a game
show almost in this video,
'cause it was like, this one
guy was just refusing to cry.
And then right at the final
clip like the sixth one
is like a fucking tear as he's like.
(Joey laughing) soo funny.
- That's so funny.
- But yeah as they were describing like,
this woman was describing
what was in the clips,
did I show you?
It just hurt describing it,
I was fucking like tearing
up on the Yamanote Line,
so fucking sad 'cause
it was something like
there was so like a kid's mom passes away
and he's helping with his dad only
and he is like is so fucking sad.
Holy fuck, I don't want
to go through that.
- I don't know, man it's like,
- I know there's nothing wrong
with like crying in public.
I don't know this is.
- Is not like full on, I'm
just like shedding you tears.
- No, but even like shedding tears,
like I have like I don't know,
I have some kind of restriction with it.
- I think it's just a
subconscious mental block.
I don't know 'cause I have
exactly the same thing
and I wish I could like bring
out my emotions more easily,
but because it takes me
so many fucking steps
to get to that point.
You know that's why.
- I don't give a fuck though,
(all laughing) A lot of things in public.
- It's not about giving a
fuck like I don't give a fuck.
I don't know something.
- Do you give a fuck?
- No I'm not like, I'm like in my head,
I'm like cry, cry, cry, cry, cry.
- No! (all laughing)
- And then something my
brain is just like no,
don't do it, don't do it.
- I guess there is like some it's,
you know just mental block that even
when you know you should
it's like your brain
is like but don't.
- Yeah, I think it was just
the way I was raised, I guess.
So somethings, sometimes you've realize,
man the way you were, how
you're raised as a kid
is pretty fucking important too.
'Cause it like affects how your like,
how you subconsciously think
for like the rest of your life.
And it takes so much more
effort to unlearn something,
than to like relearn.
Which is like learned
something for the first time.
- Did you ever like catch
yourself doing something
that your parents used to do
to you when you were a kid,
like the way they would talk of it like?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I remember like, I
think what was it like?
My dad used to have
this really specific way
of making excuses up.
I caught myself doing it
one time and I was like,
fuck I picked it up.
- Is that moment where you're
like shit, I am my dad's kid.
- (all laughing) Fuck!
- I'm becoming.
- I thought I was
superior this whole time,
but I was just equal.
- That's the thing right?
It's like you listened to your dad
all your life.
- You know all the bullshit
that your parents do.
You listen to it all your life
and then when you get to like
your teens and you hear it,
you make fun of them for being like,
- I'm never gonna be like.
- And then years later you
catch yourself doing it
and be like, oh no! (laughs)
- I was the same this entire time.
- Yeah, it's been a lot of like.
- Always has been
- I've had to like physically like
and mentally just be like,
don't do this, don't do this,
don't do this thing.
'Cause I thought they
were like weird things,
nothing bad but like just little quirks
that my parents would do that.
- It's just like certain
ways you say things
where you're just like, this
is the first time me saying it
but for some reason I've heard it before.
- Yeah, yeah, you are
like fuck my parents,
they planted the seeds.
(All laughing)
- Oh my God.
- But yeah, I mean, Anahona,
I still love it to this day.
- Made, made, I surely love the word made.
- If that's the case,
what anime would you recommend
to someone to make them cry?
What's it?
- Golden Time.
- What is that Golden Time?
- Is that the right name?
- Yeah, Golden Time
- I always fucking call it
something different by accident
like golden week or some shit.
- To me Golden Time is
in the same categories
as Anahona for like.
- It's a cult though, I
like the cult, I'm kidding.
(both laughing)
I just found that whole
call awkwardly dumb
and I really enjoy how stupid that
- I can't even remember that.
- I can't even remember.
- There was a part where
she was like brainwashed
in a cult or some shit
that happened, I think so.
I don't know, I'm basically
a patient in waiting.
So I mean I'm probably the wrong person.
- I definitely didn't get a cry bone a lot
from watching Golden Time.
- What is another show that
it's like really good cry upon?
An anime.
What's the best Cry Porn Anime?
- I mean anything by
- Shinkai
- Jun Maeda right?
- Yeah, anything Maeda
Jun, anything Shinkai.
- I'm not one of those people who knows.
- Okay Maeda Jun is like,
Clannad, AngelBeats,
Little busters anything
by Keys studios basically,
it's like pretty good cry porn..
- I didn't find any Angelbeats
as sad as everyone else,
cause I felt like.
- I cried because of the angels.
- It was obvious it was
gonna happen though.
- I felt exactly the same way.
It was my same problem with Clannad,
just less stretched out
where he was so obviously
trying to make you cry.
It was yeah, it's literally just Cry Porn
where you just.
- He was going to cry, he
was crying, aren't you?
- Sometimes just to like make you cry
and make you shed tears.
- Yeah, but I have like an initial,
like my Cry Porn was raw card
the moment I see Maeda Jun,
you know what I mean?
It's like, I know it's like,
I don't even have to watch it
and I'm already prepared, you know?
- So I just googled Saddest
anime, just Saddest anime
and Google says, number one, Anohana.
(all laughing)
- See Emily? Even Google agrees.
- Plastic Memories, which is was.
- Plastic Memories it's okay.
- I wish you knew again.
- It was just basically
Kansa with waifu's waiting.
It's like it was.
(both laughing)
- It's like I Want To Eat Your Pancreas.
- Actually I Want To Eat Your
Pancreas fucking brilliant.
- I Want To Eat Your
Pancreas is a fucking cry.
- Angel Beats.
- Angel Beats, okay.
- Madoka Magica
- Madoka, I didn't cry at
the end of Madoka Magica.
- There's a difference
between sad and bleak.
I feel like Madoka Magica here
is more on the bleak side.
- Madoka Magica is like grief crying.
(Garnt laughing)
- There's Guilty Crown.
- (Garnt laughing) Guilty Crown? Why?
- I cried because of
how bad the ending was,
if that's what they mean by that.
- Was a Stein's actually, you know what?
I really liked Guilty
Crown, I would just say it.
I like it.
- The ending though?
- I like all of Guilty Crown.
Really?
- Yeah.
- You know what Connor, I'm
absolutely there with you.
- (both laughing) Yes, yes.
It's the one fucking
time me and Connor agree.
- People need to stop comparing
it to as a Code Geass.
Code Geass is in it's its own world.
- How do you compared to that
I don't compare to Code Geass
but I still thought
the ending was amazing.
- It wasn't the best ending of the world,
but man it was a fucking good run.
- It was entertaining as fuck.
- It was beautiful
- Did you cry though?
- I think I probably did.
- I was actually this close to crying
and that's it wasn't because of the story,
it was just because of how.
- The music.
(laughing loudly)
- The beeps and the boops were soo hype.
- Okay here's the thing,
the thing about me in crying is that
music has so much more power
over me (mumbles) does.
- Oh yeah.
- That's if there's a good soundtrack,
I'm like almost always close to crying.
- Okay, why do you think I cried,
to everything Maeda Jun does?
Because he makes the music as well,
which makes me cry like a bitch.
But like, I don't know like I liked it,
the Guilty Crown had it's
like emotional moments
and obviously, you know
the soundtrack was good,
but like, I don't know,
my cry bone was like a
half child the entire time.
I was like,
- I really liked it.
- It's like it was so close.
- Maybe it's because I haven't watched it
in four or five years, but
maybe it's Garnt tinted glasses
I'm looking through an app
and I really enjoying it.
- I really enjoyed it
not in the sense where,
hey I'm gonna recommend
this as a good show.
I really enjoyed it in the sense
where it was just here's
a lot of dub anime tropes
that I enjoy.
I'm not gonna, I don't
care if they make any sense
whether they put these anime tropes in,
but (laughs) it's just like
a lot of good popcorn fun.
- Yeah, that's was great show.
- Yeah, it's kind of reminds me,
I remember when Darling
In The Franxx first aired,
I called Darling In The
Franxxto guilty crown
of this generation (Joey
and Connor laughing)
And I kind of still agree
with myself on that point
where Darling In The
Franxx got stupid as fuck
but he was entertainingly stupid.
- Of course.
- Yeah I mean, the thing about
Darling In The Franxx is that
I went through a whole
fucking emotional arc with it
because it was the first half I would say
was actually legitimately good.
- Did you watch your weekly by the way?
- Yeah, I did watch weekly.
So I already thought that
Darling In The Franxx
was a great character drama with MXNet
and I was super, super
emotionally invested,
in this as a series.
And then the fucking space
thing happens and then it went.
- More trigger was like,
let me introduce myself.
- Yeah exactly, and my enjoyment
for Darling In The Franxx
kind of just shifted off that.
I didn't, I wasn't emotionally
attached to anymore,
it wasn't that same kind of enjoyment,
it was just the look at all
this happening out of enjoyment.
- I think when you watch a show weekly,
I think like you're almost more likely
to think it's better than it is, if it's
like holding your attention.
- I disagree.
- Really?
- I think watching something
like not having to wait
and just marathoning
something I've enjoyed shows
that I haven't enjoyed weekly
that I've watched a of marathons.
- Really like what?
'Cause I almost find
that when you wait a week
for something that you're
kind of excited for, right,
you almost like hype yourself up for it,
unlike, think that it's
like, how written it is.
- It's hard for me to say though,
because haven't watched an anime weekly
since like High School.
- Been were watching Re:Zero weekly.
And I think maybe there's an aspect
of me that thinks it's better
because the mystery being
like drip fed because of having
to wait a week at a time.
- Right but I think that only works
because it's a mystery, right?
- I actually Re:Zero is that exact show.
I remember kind of like,
I remember enjoying it watching it weekly
and I kind of only kept up
with it cause it was my job.
And I remember re-watching it all at once
after there was no
pressure to like keep up
little bit of review.
And I enjoyed it way more
watching it all at once
and not having to wait weekly
even though I knew what was gonna happen.
And that's why I haven't
like I've kept up kind of
with Re:Zero Season Two,
but I watch it in chunks.
I'm not completely up to date with it.
- Cause I wonder,
cause I watched Attack on
Titan season three, four, two.
Is that the title?
- Like the latest one.
- I watched that weekly.
Yeah, the latest one.
And I don't know if it's because like,
it's I watched it weekly and
every single week was like,
oh my God, I have to wait
a week, this is so hype.
This is the best thing ever.
But like in my memory,
season three part two
which is fucking like God, God tear
- I marathon did and it was still do.
- It's still like that
amazing even if like.
- Or I mean I don't know
how you're feeling about it.
- Obviously like it's
pretty one of the best anime
I've ever watched if not
like it's like top two.
- I mean I binged the
entire thing in a day.
It's so, it's fucking amazing.
- it's fucking amazing.
We've already sung the
praises of talking title a ton
on this podcast.
- I think that's one of the few ratios
where it's like weekly or not.
It's just objectively
a fucking great show.
You know like the experience
I think is just as powerful.
- Spoiler Alert just for
like one minute here.
Whenever the video comes up my recommended
of Levi versus the Beast
Titan, I'm like, I've got time.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I've got time for three more minutes
of that Spoiler Warning.
(all laughing)
- Yeah lets agree.
- Well, we somehow got
onto good anime now,
let's go back to that
anime, the worst anime ever.
- I don't know what I mean.
- What's like a famous,
like what's like a show
that is like, not universally praised
but it's like, not like,
it's not like Garzey's Wing
like Mass Destruction
where like the only reason
why it's known is because it's bad.
- I don't know because, here's the thing
if there's a bad anime,
I'm likely not to watch it
or finish it right.
Because, okay here's the
thing, if something's
as bad as Garzey's Wing or something
then I'm gonna finish it.
But I still think it's good
because it gives me some
kind of entertainment value.
What I don't like the
worst thing an anime can do
for me is just be boring.
- It's B made.
- I'm not going to lie.
I got to High School kind
of shit, kind of shit.
I'm going to say, it's kind of boring.
- You mean God of Mid-school?
- (Joey laughing) God of Mid-school.
- When I made a tweet
about Rental girlfriend.
There was like three people
who were like God of High School
is the best anime of the season.
I'm like, what season did you watch it?
- Watching God of High School
just makes me so disappointed.
I'm like the disappointed, because I look
at some of these fight scenes
and I still think choreography
and animation wise,
it's probably some of
the best fight scenes you
can find all year so far.
I can't think of a better anime.
- I think we've said like,
it's pretty just disappointing
because it was so popular.
- Yeah.
And I don't know, I've heard
from a lot of Webtunes Readers
that it basically skipped
through everything
and just gave you the fights.
- That's not how to do it.
- Exactly, but I mean, it just
gave me the feeling of just
I don't know, watching like
a very good fight animation
on like YouTube was something where,
you have these fight scenes
and it would've worked
better being clipped
and put onto YouTube with no context
than it would have been in like,
- That's what I watched like,
'cause I didn't actually watch the anime.
I just saw the clips on
YouTube and I'm like,
there's some cool fight
scenes, but is it enough
for me to get invested into the show?
Probably not.
- I watched like 10 episodes
of Narrotor like last year.
- Why?
- Because I wanted to get it.
- Wait for season.
- Yeah.
- Like as kids narrator?
- Yeah, like the very.
- Okay.
- And that was horrible
because, (Joey laughing)
I was like, oh my God, even
the story feels like fella.
- Yeah, that's why I
never got into Narrator.
- I'm like, I'm watching
this and I'm 10 episodes in,
and I'm like nothing has happened.
We've like left the village
and we've gone like,
I've watched more opening and ending
than I have like show development.
And then that annoying show in thing,
which I think should be
like, it should be illegal.
You shouldn't be put
in prison if you do it
while you put four minutes
of the previous episode
at the start of the
episode after the intro.
So it's only six minutes of like,
that you've already seen
and don't need to see
like 43,
- We call that shown in recap syndrome.
- 14 minutes to the actual episode.
And then like seven minutes actual
somehow they find a way
- To last like six of
some One Piece of that.
- Yeah that's I was about to say,
I don't know how there are still anime.
only watches of One Piece when that is.
That was like literally every episode
for the past six years.
- Cause I remember the
last I watched One Piece,
was the Punk Hazard dog.
And literally every
fucking episode was like,
here's an extended opening.
And then 10 minutes of filler,
five minutes of actual content
and then an extended ending.
- It's cause there's only one.
They only adapt like one
chapter per episode times.
And you know, granted the
chapters are dense as fuck.
You compare the chapters
today of One Piece
to like some of the early chapters.
And it's like the like
added to like a light novel
into his chart in between these dialogue.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
And it's so small and
it's so concentrated.
But yeah I mean it still doesn't add up
to like one entire anime
episode worth of content
in my opinion though.
So yeah reread the Manga of One Piece.
- Why should I Gigguk?
It's too long Gigguk.
It's it's too fucking big.
- That's the worst argument
I've ever heard of anime.
- What do you mean?
I don't want it's like, why
you get a degree Connor?
It's only four years come on, man.
Why aren't you doing it?
It's so good for you.
I got degree and it was shit
- Okay, but
- Yeah but if enjoyed the degree.
- Okay what if there's this
really good thing right?
do you want it to like end quickly
or do you want it to keep going
on for as long as possible?
'Cause that's One Piece, right?
Like you're talking about
it like it's a commitment.
If you're into One Piece.
- It is, it is a commitment.
- Like you can say the
same to my Jojo anime
- I guess yeah, but then at
least Jojo this like part.
So you can like
- Yeah would One Piece there's Arcs.
- Arcs of different departs though.
- I don't know man I stopped
at the Punk Cassadaga
and I could easily go back to it.
- I wouldn't feel
comfortable stopping mid Arc.
- No, no, no, but that's thing
- I'm sorry between.
I wouldn't feel comfortable.
- No, no but that's why I
ended until the Arc was over
to like take a break.
- Yeah but I wouldn't feel
comfortable doing that.
- Why?
- Because it's the same show.
It's the same characters.
They're still doing this adventure.
I'm not finished.
I can't just stop.
- It doesn't matter because
it's going to get shown
in recap syndrome at the
beginning of the next one anyway.
- Oh my God!
- So it doesn't matter.
- I just, I think the thing is because,
it's also daunting for the fact that
if I get into it, it's great
that there's that much.
But it's also terrifying
that this, that much
- But that's the thing
like you're saying it
in the pretense of like,
I'm probably not going to
enjoy One Piece, right?
I'm saying what's worrying is
if I do enjoy, because I'm not
going to get anything
done for like five years
I'm going to be there.
Just fucking reading
about how loofy his arms
had ripped off by like,
- I completely get what
you're saying because I was
I was having this thought experiment.
So if I wasn't already into One Piece,
what'd you get into could I convince,
could it could future
me or could like I could
could I convince an
alternate universe of me
who hasn't seen One Piece
to now get into One Piece?
And I'm like, that is so difficult,
I don't know how I would convince myself
to get into One Piece.
But I mean.
- Our schedule was already pretty rammed
with not reading Manga and
the Manga I do get to read
is very small parts.
And I wouldn't want to read something
because I don't read
several Mangas at one go.
I read one Mongo at a time.
- Yeah.
- I read it all and go onto the next.
And I don't know why my brain,
just can't I don't really enjoy.
- 'Cause I'm not.
- I'm exactly the same as
Connor, when I'm into something
when I'm into something has to
be that I am into something.
I literally lost fucking
two days of doing nothing
because I caught up to rental a girlfriend
and that was just like my
obsession for that two days.
And if your friends, a
girlfriend is like 500 chapters
I would have just lost like.
- Oh yeah, yeah, no, I dedicated
like an entire month just reading bulky.
- How many chapters of One Piece?
- Almost a thousand.
- Yeah, but like on the
flip side, on the flip side
I really value that because it's so
like part of me is like
part of me of like has,
who is someone who has been an anime
and Manga fan for so long.
I kind of missed the feeling
like you had as a kid where
you could just lose an
entire week to just to just
watching this anime.
Because is it like, is
it, am I that you guys are
the same way?
It's like so hard for you
to like marathon stuff now.
- Yeah, like, especially if
it's like over 12 episodes
it's really hard for me, I'm like,
it's really hard for me
to marathon something
but that's why when I'm like
into a show and I'm like
properly into it and I'm just losing days
I really value that.
- Yeah.
- And I search for it wherever I can.
But it's so hard for me to find like,
even if there's like
technically a good show
or a good series, which I can say,
yeah, this, this is a good show.
I felt really fucking good like
when I finally marathon Demon Slayer
in like two days.
- Yeah.
- I was like, I haven't felt
I actually finished a show
that was more than 12 episodes.
What the fuck?
- Yeah, I missed the
feeling of just having days
and time passed where you're not
like when you're not like.
- I was discussing
What, how, why it sucks to be a adult.
(Connor laughing)
Damn, I just have like no time
- No time to marathon,
like working all the time.
But like, I will say that
if you do one that feeling
just get into One Piece.
- 1000 chapters doesn't sound that bad.
Like I read all of I shields.
- There volumes of Jojo
than there is One Piece.
- Is there more chapters of,
oh I guess there's this tendency more?
I mean, I read five through
seven of Jojo in like,
I think just over a week.
- Yeah, yeah you could easily get
from like the Alabaster
Loc, to like the Mermaid
- That was like a week
of me sitting in my bed
with a cup of tea nonstop just like
- Yeah.
(Joey laughing)
- But that's the thing, right?
It's like, if you get into it,
then it won't really matter.
- That's the problem is that
I'm going to lose three
weeks of my life minimum.
- You're gonna enjoy the cluster.
- You're gonna remember those
three weeks of your life
and your you're going to look back.
- I have to show for it, go.
- And then you'll finally
be able to come jump
into a conversation about One
Piece and being like, yeah
if there was like an X pocket
sheet, like a real life
X-Box achievement where you
can be like, I've read one
and you can have like this badge that says
you've read One Piece.
And it's like something
about my driving license
tangible to show for it.
You have to invest yourself
is what I'm hearing.
- Yeah, I guess I don't really
how much free time do I have?
It kind of varies I guess on the day.
Like some we use YouTube, right?
So some days I'm walking all day nonstop.
Some days I'm sitting
there trying to think
of a video idea and nothing happens.
And I just didn't do anything all day.
Play the game of league
maybe, I don't know..
But like if I read something
it's so hard to see that
as like a, I'm not the type
of person who reads casually.
It's like, if I read, I need to like focus
and decide that I'm going to
read and it be a long thing.
I can't just be like, yeah
I'll read a chapter
for five minutes again.
- I can't do that.
- There's people I know
who can pick up a book
read two pages and be
like, nice that was good,
I'm gonna go do the rest, I'm like what?
- Yeah.
- What, that's like,
that's like getting a semi
and being like at a good
wank (Joey laughing)
- I need like a minimum
of like five chapters
to fully get myself in
in like the reading zone.
And then once I'm in that zone, I'm like,
okay don't talk to me.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's like that sense of flow.
You know what I mean?
- I don't understand people
who can like read a book
and watch a movie at the same time,
or like have the TV on,
in the background.
- On the background, can
you pay attention to it?
- I need complete silence.
- Oh yeah, that's because like every time
I'd like, Akira story
she comes into, you read
your Manga, like what woman?
And it's like, there's
no noise in the room.
- I need my total peace to read this.
- He's holding like fat lolly acids
volume one and what this is woman?
I can't, you see I'm reading literature.
(both laughing)
- Oh yes.
(all laughing)
- Make it a Manga, I don't know.
- That's an oxymoron, isn't it?
- It's like a color book.
- (all laughing) It's a
draw Manga, coloring book.
- All right, boys, I have
a question I want to know.
Is there any anime out
there that you, you know
maybe have a hot take on like
an anatomy that you think is
either really good anatomy
that you like that is
highly praised and widely
accepted to be amazing
that you think isn't that good?
Or is there a show
that everyone thinks that
you think is pretty good?
- Jury's already had his with school cars.
- You know, I've really
loved the Cabo bebop dub
but the show itself, I didn't
think it was like that good,
I'm gonna to be honest.
Like I liked it, but I didn't think
it was like the masterpiece worthy.
Like everyone says, it's like.
- I hate that, I can disagree with you.
- like it's, like the dub.
- Like it's
- I've heard Samurai
Champloo a million times.
- Yes, yes.
- Nah, nah, a million times more.
- I was about to say I have
exactly the same opinion
just with Samurai Champloo.
- No, Samurai Champloo was
a million times better.
- To me, like this, like
I don't know what it was
about Samurai Champloo
I thought the story, the style
and the music was amazing
and the music is amazing
particularly wrong.
- Yeah.
- But like the reasons
why I liked Cowboy Bebop
was one the dub and two,
nothing to do with the story.
I thought the story was kind
of like all right, okay.
- I just, I just feel like Cowboy Bebop
had some really interesting ideas
because it's kind of like
a couple of people up
is isn't like a long
like it doesn't have like
a very long overarching story arc.
It's more of these individual ideas
you know, that's once
an IRB wants to explore
and I thought it had
some really good ideas
and so did Samurai Champloo but
I don't know something
about Samurai Champloo
just made me feel like the idea
is just one is interesting
individual level.
- Can you, can you sit
here and like say to me
that Cowboy Bebop deserves
to be like in the top five
as it always is on every single piece?
- Yes.
- Really, top five?
like when I see it all time.
Like when I see it, it's like those people
who put Citizen Kane at number one on.
It's like yeah, I know movies,
Citizen Kane's my favorite,
I know the movie.
- I is a Rosebud, my favorite quotes.
- It's like, when I see that
on someone's like top five,
I immediately think they're
like trying too hard
to be a quick cause to me I don't think
of animated like a critical
sense most of the time.
- I just thought when I watched it,
I was like it's really
cool, tons of style.
I just thought the story was kind of mad.
- Yeah, I mean, if you get,
if you go into for like
a big story, then it's just a show.
- Okay, so what about the
Samurai Champloo story
was good then.
- Okay, it has been a long
time since I've watched both.
- Is the same here, same here.
- But I don't know, I remember
just having a ton of fun
every single episode of Samurai Champloo.
- To me the story and like character,
like how much I enjoyed the
story and the characters
about Samurai or Champloo,
Cowboy Bebop around equal.
- Yeah.
- It was everything else around the show,
like the music, the sound
effects, like the animation stuff.
that made Samurai Champloo
just that much better.
- I did not give a about the
annoying kid on Cowboy bebop.
- I mean, I didn't give
a fuck about Fuu for like
what are they trying to do again?
- [Hosts] Finding the Samurai
that smells like sunflowers.
Like the plot doesn't matter an E the show
- I just liked the
characters Samurai Champloos.
Like I thought, because
we had only three of them.
It was like, we got a lot more
time to like flush it out.
Whereas they just brought
this sidekick character
and a dog and I'm like, why?
- To be fair, I love Iron though.
- Yeah, he's...
- Iron is great.
- Iron is spike is like one
of the coolest anime
characters of all time jet.
- I think Mugen was cooler,
to be honest with you
(Garnt laughing) just saying
I think Mugen was way cooler than Spike.
I think spike is dope
But if I had to like
say which one was cool,
I'd definitely Mugen.
- Spike can beat Mugen (all laughing)
- Microsoft (all laughing)
You have a bike able
to survive AIDS though?
- My character can beat up your character,
have you thought about that?
You're going to do swing
your Samurai sword,
Spike and just shoot him then.
- (all laughing) Mike, Mike, where's Mike?
- I mean, I don't know,
I know this has been one of those shows,
that I do think is great but just
whenever I see it in top fives,
I'm like, you're just shining out of your.
- Yeah, okay like I have
a very similar opinion
not of cowboy bebop, but just.
- Even galleon?
- Akira,
Akira, I think (laughs)
- I think you guys get
a shout (Garnt laughing)
- I think Akira is Mid as fuck.
- Ah, you're dead to me.
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
You are absolutely dead to me.
- I think, I think it's
one of those things
where it came out at the time
and it was a game changer at the time,
but I don't think now it
holds up, it's still a game.
- We watched it several
times trying to find
what about it, amazing,
and every time we want you,
I'm like man the animation
still holds up the whole time.
It's just like, it just, it's just,
I don't know, it's just
nothing much better.
- You want to share your thoughts on that?
- This is my last episode of trash.
I'm leaving after this.
I can't handle it.
Okay, okay.
All right, Akira to me is like,
I think to this day it still stands
as one of the most unique
cinematic experiences in anime
and I'm not just talking.
- You're wrong.
- I agree with that.
- And I'm not talking about that in terms
of like the flashy
colors and the fantastic.
Yeah, ooh, it looks pretty
like I'm not just talking
about it like that, right?
But like, I just, I don't know like
I've rewatched the Akira so many times
and every time I've rewatched it,
especially like you have to
see it in a big screen as well.
In my opinion, like I went to go see it.
Okay, cause I went to go watch it.
Obviously I wasn't born
when it came out in cinemas
but like a couple of years
ago they did a re-screening
of it in Sydney, in Australia at four
I think it was like the 30th anniversary
of the movie or something
on the big screen.
And like, I loved it on the TV
like watching it in my room
and was like fuck yeah.
But watching it in the
cinemas was like, Holy shit.
Like this is like an adventure.
Like this is, this is
just like such an out
of body experience with
just the music is God like,
the voice acting is incredible.
Like everything about that has
every, every single element
of that movie has a quality that can still
stand to like modern anime, cinema empire.
And like, and I think that's
why it's just so incredible
because you watch it
and you forget, Oh shit.
this was made 30 years ago.
- Yeah, but that's my point.
I completely agree that it's
an experience that can stand
out in modern anime cinema.
It's but I'm saying
it's, it's definitely not
as mind blowing as it was back then.
And I mean, I think
it's still mind-blowing
- Every time I rewatched it, I was like
- I feel like I can agree with both.
- I'm not saying it's
the best Anime movie.-
- No, no, Of course.
- Of course.
- But, Jesus Christ, it's good.
Like I could easily have
you read the Manga though?
- I have not.
I think that's part of
why I didn't enjoy it.
'Cause it just felt like it
felt like it kind of just ended.
It was, it didn't feel
like a complete experience.
- Well, yeah.
- Well does the Manga continue after?
- The Manga is twice as long.
So the movie actually
the movie, the ending
of the movie is completely original.
Because Ultima released the movie halfway
into a curious serialization
because the first like
three volumes was so
popular that they were like
we gotta make a movie
of this and they made it
but they were like, I haven't
finished the monkey yet.
What am I going to do.
- Bro? I'm trying to finish it.
- So the movie is completely original
and like the Munga continues for another
like four volumes off to
the point of the movie.
And it's insane, it's fucking insane.
Like I highly recommend it,
and I'm not just saying it
as like a super fan of Akira.
I just think in terms of like storytelling
am just like, you know,
I'm just throwing key tones
(all laughing) honestly,
story telling.
- Characters, development.
- Like honestly though, it's good shit.
- Whoa, how many more buzz
words can I throw in here?
- Four progression synergy?
- All right.
- Again I don't think
it's the greatest piece
of like anime cinema
out there, but like, I
I easily, it's one of
those movies where I'm like
don't be fooled by the fact
that it's 30 years old.
I still think I can easily
recommend it to new watches.
- You can definitely still watch it today
and not feel like it's dated.
Especially as like, as like a, for me
like a visual experience and everything.
I just feel like, you
know, it's I don't know
maybe it's cause like cyberpunk
has just kind of died recently.
I mean, for the longest time
until what recent cyberpunk
Academy we got recently
like Dora head.
- Yeah.
- It's I mean, seeing, seeing a world
like that is a lot less,
you know, a single word
like that now is a lot less
common than it was back then.
But cyber punk was kind of in its prime.
- Eighties was like, like, say like...
- So like you can still
watch a Kiran feel like,
hey this is something I
can't really get today
just because cyber punk is just
it's really rare to find out.
- Because to me like Akira
is like one of those movies
like those anime movies,
where every single person I've asked
who is clearly not an anime fan
and I asked them, what anime
have you watched or enjoyed?
99% of them will say,
oh, I watched the Akira
and I thought it was fucking amazing.
- Yeah, it's just a good movie.
- It's just a really good movie.
It almost defies anime in a
sense which is really weird
because it is (all laughing)
which is really weird.
- Wait, wait, wait, how
what'd you mean defies anime?
What does that mean, what does that mean?
- Like it goes like it an
enjoyment factor in it,
I can't exactly like describe,
I'm sure if someone can
explain it better than me,
but doesn't it there's
some thing about Akira,
the experience of watching Akira
that you don't necessarily
even have to really like animates.
Which is really weird, because
I actually watch Akira,
It is animated fuck.
Like everything about that is so anime
and yet it somehow is almost
not anime at the same time.
It's really hard I don't
know how to explain it.
- I can relate to what you're saying,
just to throw out my second heartache
I guess.
- Go on.
I don't know if I've said
this on the Podcast before
but I think I've said it in other places.
- But I hate Ghibli movies man (laughs).
- I only liked like three.
- I think I like one or two and even like.
- Which ones?
- Princess Manake and NASCA
- Do you like House Moving Castle?
- No.
- I really like House Moving Castle.
- The reason I don't like Ghibli is
just because I don't like Disney.
And I don't know because Ghibli, like
when I see a Ghibli movie
I'm like, this is an anime
like this is an animate,
this is a fucking Ghibli movie.
- Can we also talk about how Miyazaki
as like fucking asshole?
- Oh yeah, he's an absolute con.
- Did you see the clip of
like him going to his sons?
- Are you going to
recommend that clip as well?
- To this clip, right?
You can search for it, but
he goes to his son's premier,
who's making a movie right? A Director
and he walks out of the premiere halfway
through being like, he's not an adult yet.
And I'm like, oh, he's one of those dads.
Who's like, he's not,
he's not an adult yet,
'cause I haven't deemed him worthy.
It's like, shut the up.
- Yeah, he goes up lit a cigarette
and it's just like,
yeah, this movie's trash,
you could have done better.
He hasn't grown up enough.
It's like, are you fucking kidding me?
- As if, as of me as like
he hasn't made movies himself, right?
Like not every, like I love
Ghilbi don't get me wrong
but have I enjoyed every
single Ghilbi movie?
Absolutely not.
- I just hate the kind of Director
who is like everyone else is unimportant
than my ideas are the best.
And you know, he sees me,
he gives off that vibe
and as much as you know cultural icon for,
you know many parts and
you don't want to be
an asshole you don't want to,
talk to anyone for no reason.
Because every single time
you see him in an interview
or do anything he just seems
kind of like a come to be around.
You would hate to be around him.
- You can tell, like he's
such a close minded dude
because apparently the only
movie that Miyazaki is like
he has made that he himself
cried too, was the Wind Rises.
And I can tell you that is the most
amid Ghilbi movie I've ever watched.
- I've heard good things about it.
- It's good.
But compared to other Ghibli
movies, it is misfolded.
- What are your favorite
Ghibli movies then?
- Princess Monaca is easily my favorite.
I mean, obviously I grew up watching like
Now star and stuff like that.
How's movie castle is really good.
I thought Ponyo was okay.
- Ponyo was boring as fuck man.
- I think Ponyo is very much the Jubilee
of the new generation, oh, sorry,
The Totoro of the new generation.
- Totoro, oh my fucking God,
I fell asleep during Totoro man I'm like,
why am I watching a kid's show now.
Why do you expect me.
- To be fair, yes,
Totoro is a kid's movie.
That's why I don't recommend
it is it's a kid's movie
- But so it's Toy story,
but I can watch toy story.
- Toy Story, the Pixar has done a thing
where they've managed to get intermingle
like very adult humor with them.
- But that's Kids like
media is great when it can be enjoyable
- But Japanese media does not do that.
- It does sometimes though.
- Not glibly though (laughs)
- Yeah not glibly.
- What is it the fucking one
with the pig flying a plane?
- [Hosts] Porco Rosso
- And I had to turn it off 20 minutes in,
I'm like soo fucking bored..
- I enjoyed it, but I thought it was okay,
like it's not amazing.
- Like that's basically my experience
with a lot of Ghibli movies is that
this is the most okay
film experience I've had.
And I like okay, the
reason I really can't get
into a lot of Ghibli movies, is that
they just don't feel anime, I don't know,
I don't know because they feel
like Disney movies, right?
And I know like Miyazaki
has gone on record like
criticizing a lot of anime animators
who are like then they're
just like inspired
by other people working in
anime inspired by real life.
And I'm like, this is why
I go into the medium dude,
I like that.
- What do I hate that.
- I hate the thing that I like as well.
- It was a mistake.
- On top of that, knowing
that he's an it makes it
so much worse for me to
like try and enjoy it
because I think you can make great ship
without being a huge camp.
- Like absolutely.
- I think maybe if you cure
every single type of cancer,
you know in your lifetime,
go ahead, be asshole.
Like you probably didn't get that passed.
- You know, it's that whole thing like
you know you should separate
the creator from the creation
but sometimes it's really hard.
- It's really hard.
- When a person markets that work
so heavily as their work, right?
Like it's a homey Zacky
film, it's not a film,
it's a Homey Zacky film, right?
So then it's like, well,
he's kind of a camp.
So it's kind of like,
you know, yeah, I agree.
- I mean sometimes it doesn't detract
on like how good this specific work is.
Just because you enjoy work.
Doesn't mean it doesn't
necessarily mean you,
you know, you I forgot the first
thing of what I was saying.
Every time I enjoy the work doesn't mean
you can't you have to like.
- I agree with that.
But it's also like when
you don't like the work
knowing the guy is kind of you know,
you're like, God I fucking hate this.
- But most people don't know that.
- When I turned off Porco
Rosso halfway through,
I was like you're not an adult yet.
(all laughing)
You haven't done it, you haven't done it.
- I walked out of my room, cigarette.
(all laughing)
I had to walk out the room,
put my arm on the doorframe
it's not ready yet.
- It's weird though, to me like
my favorite is Miyazaki film
isn't even a Jubilee film,
it's the Lupen III movie.
(Connor laughing)
Like way before Ghilbi, the
castle will that shit's dope.
But like, yeah, I don't know it's (sighs)
- Yeah, that's great.
- I wonder was he always like that?
Or is that something that
happens when everyone
tells you you've you've come
down from God to bless us with animation?
- I would say it's the latter.
- He's also like old 150 years old.
He's retired like a eight times.
- I would like a to think,
when I get old I'll be
the fun kind of old guy.
The one who's like, I give a
about what the young people are doing.
Instead of being like, I hate life.
- You say that now.
- Yeah you say that now,
as like a 20 year old.
- I hope, I hope, that's
why I said I hope.
- I doubt Miyazaki is in
his twenties was like,
I'm going to grow up.
I'm going to grow up
to be an absolute cunt.
- I'll reject all my statements.
If I see him, you know what I mean?
If he comes out, it's
the whip, I'll forget.
I'll take (all laughing)
- Just like browsing
Twitter to be like, oh man
they think I'm an asshole,
I better change my ways.
You know, what I mean.
- They think I'm an
asshole, fuck the haters.
- I don't care what he
thinks, but I, you know, if he
if he wants to see it and
think I've, you know, whatever
but I mean, all I'm saying
is that you don't have to
be an asshole.
- Yeah exactly.
- You could be, you really
have to tell your son
his movie was in front of the cameras
and go out of this, did you really?
- Did you really have
to have the cigarette?
- This really feels like a
drive home kind of thing.
Like a son, it wasn't that
good, but don't worry.
I wasn't going to embarrass
you for all the news
outlets that were
waiting, it's your son for
for fuck's sake, are you kidding me?
- That was the thing that broke you?
- That was the thing
where I'm like, I'm like,
oh, this is too much.
You purposely went out of your way
to be a cunt, like you could have waited
till he got home and texted
her and been like son.
- Yeah, that's the thing that like the,
I watched the highlight
Zaki documentary years ago
and it was such an interesting document
because you'd get to learn
about his life and like he's
full process about everything.
- Yeah.
- But I don't recommend that
like documentary to people
nor do I want to rewatch it
because in the entire documentary,
homie was like,
he's just an absolute
dick to the interviewer..
- Yeah, it's just kind
of like, just answer the
question, like a normal person.
- It's like when people are
just making things difficult
for the sake of it, and
then you have this whole,
I'm the best, I know everything,
it's like, it's so frustrating
to have to put up with that.
Did you have to be an asshole though?
Why, why did, why?
Like, what did you gain from that?
Does that make you feel big?
Did you feel, I should feel better?
Like, just be nice.
- But like Stanley Kubrick
have the same thing, right?
Apparently Stanley Kubrick was Dick.
- Apparently directors
in general tend to be.
- When some of the most talented people
and talented visionaries are
probably some of the biggest.
- I mean, especially with the Director
where it is literally
like you have to be like
put your foot down because I think
there's a great YouTube video,
was like are all Directors dicks?
It was on my recommended
for like a million.
- I love that tittle,
are all Directors dicks?
- Yeah, that's actually really
interesting go watch it.
And it basically just he
interviews a ton of Directors
asking them, you know
should you be a dick?
A lot of them would be like, yeah
I am because I have to put
my foot down constantly
and tell them no, you know especially
if you're working with
some actors who are.
- I get being a dick on the job, right?
But like, when it's just like.
- This is what I mean like, yeah.
you can be a dick on set
to get what you need done.
But did you have to go home.
- Humiliate the interview?
- Humiliate your son,
do you have to do that?
Like that, just that, that really like
I didn't know what it
was when I saw that clip
it really struck a nerve with me.
I was like, I didn't mind him
being an asshole sometimes,
I was a guy like
whatever, that's his thing
and then the office gets it.
But then when he did that,
I'm like, that is just cruel.
- Yeah I think what hit me
about that clip was that he
did that in front of camera.
Camera's you know what I mean?
- All the other, all
the other people there
because all the other old
men came out afterwards.
Like it was good, wasn't it?
And he was like, no.
- And he just left.
I remember there was a
Shot of just him going down
the stairs and be like.
- Dragged his wife out with him.
And I'm like, Oh my
God, you guys chill out.
I'm off back home now.
- Yeah, it's just kinda like one
of those things you're like, bro.
- I don't want to be like that.
- No, I don't think I have the life.
I could do that to my kid.
- That's like your son, like making his
first YouTube video and you
just like pause and walk.
(all laughing)
- My parents didn't do that.
- They up Brunel game week.
- They pretended like they got it.
I know they didn't
but I appreciated that
they sat through it.
- Yeah, exactly, right?
- I just have this image of you
like you seeing your son
doing his first YouTube video
and it's a like reaction
video or something.
I was like, son
I expected better from
expect creativity from them.
I didn't, I didn't raise a son to meet
for him to grow up, to
be a reaction YouTuber.
- Which PC, is it in?
(mimicking breaking PC)
- Yeah, I mean it was, I don't know.
It's like I said, it struck a nerve.
Fuck, I was going to say something else.
Like totally forgot I had, fuck.
- Yeah, bottom line just don't be a Dick.
- It was like, I read an article as well.
Miyazaki actually openly said
that he was just never there
for his kids growing up.
- After that video
- Because of course he was,
- Well, that makes sense.
- YouTube is making a movie
but then that's when you want
to finally come through right?
it's your kid's movie.
You finally want to be like, son.
I know I wasn't there for you
but God you did me proud dad.
Could you imagine he
probably spent his whole
life chasing that, that moment.
One moment where he just
needed this dad to be like
you know what kid you did
good, I watched the movie.
It was better than half the
ship made is Zackey May made
I watched the movie out of pure spite.
(Joey laughing)
I don't even know what it was called.
I would've said it was the best movie.
That's it
- I haven't seen it, but I
heard it was really good.
- It's pretty bad (laughs)
- Come on, come on just say it.
- It's probably universally agreed,
it's one of the worst
movies Ghibli has ever made.
- Really? (Connor and Garnt laughing)
- Like, I feel mad.
I feel bad, but man, you know
I feel bad that Miyazaki just.
Talk to son.
Cause like, no matter
what, as a parent got to--
- I feel so much better
- This could have been a snuff film.
I would have sat through
my kid's first movie.
You know what I mean?
I'm sitting through that, like I have to.
- No matter how bad it is,
you got to have your kids back.
- Give it like, no like no parent, right?
Like goes up to their five-year-old looks
at the macaroni artwork
and goes that's shit.
- Lights up the cigarette.
- I expect a better from his son.
- Son, I saw the other kids
macaroni on it was much better
than this, you know.
- They use the gluten free.
- Okay though, have you
ever had a show or series
where you really, really
enjoyed and then something
came like you enjoyed before and then
You learnt about the
creator or the author.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- And has that like affected
your view of the show at all?
- Absolutely, when, what happened
to the Rurouni Kenshin right.
Recently act age happened.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I was enjoying act eight so much.
This is one of the most unique
Shawnee jump experiences.
And then that happened
and I was like, well fuck.
I kind of don't want to read it anymore.
- And people want to
always be like, you know
you should separate them
but it's so hard to do that when you,
you really respect the work.
- Especially Rurouni Kenshin
because like this is coming from a
massive Rurouni Kenshin film.
And I was like, I can't read it anymore.
- No, no it's it was one
of my favorites show in
Manga and anime hang up
and I still have the volumes on my shelf.
It's just like gathering dust now.
- It's, hard as well
because you almost respect
because you, the work so
much that came from the mind
and you almost respect
like the thought process
and the creativity that
came from the person right?
It all came from a mind.
I think what's disturbing
is like what all these such
amazing ideas came out of the
same head that was like, Oh
I should, I should, you know,
collect this not good stuff.
- I remember I was really
into acting as well.
And then after the news came
out, it kind of looked at some
of the, like some, some of
the plot points of that age
whereas like, like we look at
An older guy grooming this 15
year old school girl to become
like one of the best
actresses of all time.
And you're like, it was cool
without that knowledge too
to just think, Hey, you
know, maybe you're just
Trying to help her as like, as like an
Actress, you know, it was, it was like.
- But now you kind of see
like the underlying reason
as to why, he choose that.
- Now there's just this underlying reason
that just makes you really uncomfortable.
- I mean, like I can't
shake the uncomfort.
- Maybe that's a complete coincidence.
We will never know the fact
that we can now make that correlation.
It just makes it that
much more uncomfortable.
- Exactly.
- And then you see people on Twitter, like
but was it legal though?
Like what does it matter if it's legal.
- It doesn't matter.
Like, I just don't want
to support a pedophile
- Really just seeing the
replies to the Twitter
on that was just like, Oh my
God, I hate this world so much
because people clearly
like to show who I like,
but it was only one, right?
It's like, yeah, it doesn't
matter if it was only one.
- One is more than zero.
- It was only one murder,
your honor, I swear.
- Come on and give me a.
- I Wasn't a serial killer.
Give me more credit than that.
- Yeah, no, I was so disappointed in that.
I was like, why is it
always the good shows?
I wouldn't, I wouldn't even care
if it was like the
mediocre shit that like.
- The Ghazi swing, right.
- If it was like the
fucking Ghazi swing, right,
Then I'll be like, yeah, what the fuck?
and I'm like, I didn't
even enjoy it to begin with
but why is it always the
good shows that it happens?
It's always like the most talented shit.
- It's a shame, it's a shame.
- It's a shame, Stop it (laughs)
- But you know, what's not fucked up?
Our beautiful, patriarchs (laughing)
- I love these guys.
- The segues ever (laughs) I'm sorry.
- Did you really just segue?
- At least the El patrons
aren't pedophiles, right?
- Thank you, patriarchs,
I don't know what to do in your free time
but please don't do bad things,
that would be really sad.
- I just love the way you just said.
So talking about shout
out to this pedos...
- Patriots, hey?
- You know what starts
with p (all laughing)
- Shout out to this patron.
This is amazing, this technology.
- If you're not a
pedophile then make sure to
come to our page, at
patreon.com/TrashTaste
listed in the description
- Are we really doing this?
Also follow us on Twitter and sorry.
- We, we, we see the memes.
What do we normally say
at this point in a week?
Thank you for your memes
- Thank you for your memes (Joey laughing)
Thank you for your follows,
thank you for your patreons.
- It's nearly 5:00 PM for us.
We need to watch the
League of Legends while.
- We as in they.
- I think it's about it
would be ended by the time.
No, it was close to ending.
- Probably.
- It doesn't matter.
- I enjoyed this video.
- Yes.
- All right.
- I have been your wonderful host Connor
- You're welcome for us
finally talking about autonomy.
I know it's like a once in a blue moon
kind of episode and anime.
- We're still an anime podcast.
- I was doing my stuff out.
If I talk about too much anime, man
I don't watch that much.
We're going to run out of stuff.
Are you guys enjoying it?
- Yeah, bye.
(upbeat music)